good lord brothers and sisters of the
universe we're back we're back once
again this podcast is supported by many
fine sponsors let's get into him right
quick number one first and foremost what
brought to you by on it on it oh and an
IT is a human optimization website it is
a website that has evolved and grown
from the birth of this podcast ascent
essentially caused the business to form
what it's about is selling what we
deemed to be items that enhance human
performance enhance your physical
performance your mental performance
enhance your mute your mood give you
healthy choices as far as things to put
into your body and strength and
conditioning equipment we sell kettle
bells and steel maces and AB wheels and
medicine balls all these different
things like weight vests things that
really enhance functional strength if
you've never done kettlebells before
there's a fantastic series of videos
that are available at on accom and if
you've done it a few times you
understand the form the best one is
Keith Webber's extreme kettlebell cardio
workouts they're fantastic because
there's a lot of kettlebell DVDs it'll
show you like how to do the individual
exercises but they don't do the workout
with you and like make you keep up with
them I just actually have been going
back and forth with kids Keith whoever
so he's gonna be on the podcast in
October I'm very excited about that I
really want to talk to him cuz his uh
his workout DVDs are like I said my
favorite if you're thinking about doing
anything like this
please start slow if you've never worked
out you smoke cigarettes and you're
always drunk do me a favor please start
slow don't be dropping a fucking big 72
pound gorilla kettlebell in your head
because you're getting crazy and you're
trying to do it all in one day it takes
time go to on it calm oh and and I T use
the code word rogue and then save 10%
off any and all supplements and this
just in we just got in and we're
drinking it now
on it caveman coffee this is our friend
Keith Jardine and Tate have created this
company called caveman coffee because
they're both fucking caveman and they
have a relationship with a guy who grows
coffee in Colombia his family grows
coffee and they they go direct to
it's a single-source farm so it's kind
of interesting
just by happenstance because Tate is uh
takes a big coffee fanatic always has
been that dude ever since we met him but
he wouldn't go anywhere without a venti
Starbucks in his hand you know yeah he
quit alcohol and drugs and went right to
coffee then well that happens man those
do dudes that are on the program they're
in like a 12-step program they love
their coffee because it gives you a
little bit of a buzz but nobody has to
get crazy and you so you satisfy a
little bit of those demons and keep
everything cool you're giving yourself a
little something something but it's not
fucking you up so those guys love coffee
it's very rare you see like an
Alcoholics Anonymous dude who although
you're not anonymous if you tell
everybody sober by the way great I
wonder do these people also move on to
other things like like sniffing markers
no you can't do anything like that
you're not supposed to do anything
that's you know what would be the word
for it twisted you know anything where
you're feeding some some you can all
those guys are addicted to Red Bulls
yeah but that's not markers it's not
like huffing paint yeah I guess which
one's more dangerous is actually good
for you or about sniffing play-doh
that's and people who deny this listen
you have to read some articles on this
it appears that coffee has a lot of
functions a lot of benefits you know
what it is it's like every fucking thing
else you can overdo it you can overdo it
you could drink coffee all fucking day
every day and just torch your adrenals
just jack your system or you can have a
little bit of it every day
it has gives you a stimulant effect on
top of that it's rich in antioxidants
there's like a lot of good things about
coffee believe it or not it's actually
not bad for you we used to think it was
bad for you what's bad for you is
dehydration but if you drink coffee and
you still drink water and keep yourself
in order just anyway go to audit calm oh
and and I T use the code word Rogan and
save 10% off any and all supplements we
are also brought to you by nature box oh
and this Pat is eating some nature box
right now and she can attest to the
yumminess of this product these
they're very good everything's good
the whole deal a natural nuts to salt
mango almond pistachios Kapow these are
lemon pluckers pistachios mango almond
bites that's what they are I mean these
these are fucking delicious but the best
is sriracha cashews nothing can fuck
with them they're all gone when you just
have them just send me boxes of
shurochka cashews if they're listening
can I have one I have one to request and
you order like I just want to order four
packs of the the cashews but it won't
let you it won't let you order four yeah
like I want to be able to and it gives
you like a stopping point where you can
only order like three extra snacks and
then like you can only order total if I
think it's like ten like we'll have to
move into the sink is what I use my box
so fast I just want to order more yeah
well order more boxes oh yeah I don't
want to say I haven't noticed that
that's that's fucked up though you
should be able to order like 50 boxes of
just sriracha cashews only yeah and I
want it once a week can I have it once a
week
I don't it doesn't unless it's really
confusing to do that you think they
would want to add you gotta check this
before you say it I know I can't do it
I've tried it a million times they won't
let you order one a week yeah why do I
have a feeling that we're gonna find out
it's really easy to order one a week it
might be but I tried okay naturebox
anyway is very good of you really good
the problem is that you can't get enough
exactly mine goes through in three days
and that's what the total it does you
should go to a supermarket and get
actual food can't enough calories you
need more otherwise you go retarded it's
big cheddar potatoes that is what your
problem is man you just you just not get
enough nutrients I just can't leave the
house that too anyway they're delicious
zero trans fats zero high fructose corn
syrup and you could get snacks that are
low in sugar
non-gmo and without gluten and they ship
for free it's a good shit man it's
really good stuff peanut butter nom noms
are really good you ever have those
baked sweet potato fries a lot of
healthy choices - a lot of choices where
you don't feel bad eating them at all
and it's so much better than the shit
that you're gonna get from
vending machine period so if you keep it
work it's a fantastic option you know
you always have healthy snacks and they
deliver them to you so if you're like
Brian and you don't like leaving your
house they just bring them to you and if
you go to nature box.com
you're gonna get fifty percent off your
first box just go to nature box calm
so nature box calm
and you'll get 50% off your month's
first box stay full stay strong my
friends good nature box come on
chili lime pistachios oh those are good
okay but I tell you what I have a
grievance with them too then because
there's a supermarket near my house it
sells pistachios out of the shells and
once you have stash those are the shells
you like why you give them any stupid
fucking shells and pretending this is a
big bag of pistachios no this is a big
bag of shit I can't eat that you expect
me to take out before I eat how about
you just give me the fucking pistachios
I have shells all over my bed before you
it's not it's over those are good
there's delicious don't get me wrong
I'll take them over nothing however the
best option is when they're already out
of the show then you just eat the shit
out of them you can't believe how many
butts dashas you getting your fucking
face definitely cost more but it's just
it's one of those things we've just
become accustomed to it's stupid that
you got a shell on that the shells not
helping anybody naturebox should have a
nature bucket of just these rows like
sriracha roasted cashews I will I will
pay 40 bucks a month if I get a bucket
at ease
I could Kentucky Fried Chicken size
bucket anyway naturebox.com/tyler and go
there enjoy and last and finally brought
to you by stamps.com stamps calm is
another awesome way to stay inside your
house that's what we're promoting ladies
and gentlemen essentially we just want
you to stay home and consume Internet
content and lose your fucking mind
but if you go to stamps.com and click on
the microphone and enter in the code
word jay-ar e
you
we'll get a 110 dollar bonus offer which
includes a digital scale and up to 55
dollars worth of free postage what
stamps.com is is a way where you can
print from your own computer you s
postage the real deal you never have to
go to a post office again if you have
your own business like Brian does at des
quad TV where he sells all those cool
kitty cat t-shirts and now hats see
those hats all kinds of groovy shit um
hoodies right yeah because up till 5:00
a.m. shipping these from stamp stock
yeah it really does have a legit job
with stamps calm and what they do is you
know they have it so that you do
everything in your computer you printed
up with your printer you slap those
babies on your boxes and you send them
out how much easier is it then going to
the supermarket or supermarket I mean
rather so easy I couldn't even fit it in
my car what I have to do like I would
have to take four trips to the post
office now I could just do it on stamps
calm then have the the mailman just pick
it up if you were less or if you were
just slightly more organized you could
have an actual business with all these
pictures right you just you have to do
it by yourself and so almost like I'm
watching one of those old-time wagon
wheels go down a hill yes and I'm like
yeah it's rolling right now but I used
to get a B before that fucking playing
at the rock if you look at my house
right now cuz I moved all the merch to
my house now and I'm doing it all for my
living room it looks like I'm a psycho
and it looks like my bed is just fucking
the the pistachio shells and in my
living room it's just boxes shirts and
bought like yes times I hire employees
man it's time to hire employees take
this shit to the next level
how dare you without stamps calm he
would be dead there would be no time for
him to eat breathe or drink water and
he'd have died long ago but what steps
Toccata brian has been able to maintain
a healthy business anyway go to
stamps.com
again entering the code word JRE and you
will get a free digital scale and up to
55 bucks worth of free postage if you
have an idea in your head and you're
thinking about starting a business if
you actually do it it will make your
life infinitely better if you could
figure out a way to get off the tip of
whatever giant company
work for that doesn't give a fuck about
you and replace you with somebody else
in the heartbeat and figure out
something you like to do man like if you
like to make fucking corncob pipes or
something if you like to you know
whatever you like to do there's a way
that someone can sell things online that
just didn't exist before and maybe it's
just something you never considered but
brainstorm seriously brainstorm come up
with a business you can start yourself
you could do it with Squarespace and
stamps.com and you would be just set you
could actually work for yourself and you
don't get to a point where you'll feel
comfortable enough to quit that
janky-ass fucking job it's been weighing
down your soul and it doesn't even have
to be a job one of the weirdest things
is that I never used the post office
because it was such a pain in the ass to
send like my family shit back home or my
friends and stuff you just have to put
it shit in a box and it cost like eight
dollars for them to get it in two days
and they come and pick it up and your
priority so now I'm just sending shit
all the time to friends and stuff just
because it's like seriously super cheap
like oh hey have some shit hey here's
this remember this yeah you get a lot of
swag right aren't you always getting
things like I almost getting t-shirts
that I'm gonna wear books that I'm not
gonna read exactly yeah that's cool if
you could share that shit to be able to
do it through stamps.com anytime look
the idea of the post office or you know
any company that sends you things is
ridiculous
you're gonna give you someone how much I
gotta give you 80 bucks and you're gonna
take some shit that weighs 20 pounds
across the country what the fuck is that
that's ridiculous it's amazing like
people used to complain about stamps
when a stamp was like 35 cents you know
it wouldn't 35 cents I'm sucking
thirty-five cents
someone's gonna take your letter and
they're gonna bring it to another part
of the world like that's amazing they're
gonna take it to the other side of the
continent and it only cost 35 cents and
you're whining you fucking lazy spoiled
bitch yeah I love the future shit like
this is a great example of a website
taking something that sucked and making
it so much better and so much easier to
where you could take advantage of the
USPS you know for like you know sending
stuff to your parents for cheap and not
having to deal with taking it to the
post office waiting
line two where it becomes a chore yeah
we have a bunch of our friends who use
the Tom Segura and christina pazsitzky
use temps calm Bert uses it crusher uses
it for Bert Bert Bert all his shit or
it's squirt doc yeah does Joey use it
for his stuff probably anyway stamps
calm go their gate freak on use the code
word GRE save them some money and enjoy
a nice product all right miss Patty's
here why fuck around Brian cue the music
don't don't fuck with nick Diaz's voice
today experience thank you don't want to
fuck with this boy you're just signed to
fight Anderson Silva Oh miss Pat now if
I did not have you on this podcast I
would have never heard the end of it
jesus fucking christ I don't know what
you've done those other podcasts but all
I keep hearing is dude you got to get
miss Pat you got to get miss Pat like
more than any recent comedian I could
think of in like the past two years
people been trying to get you what's
going on ladies I guess I think I'm the
nanny and shit well what I keep hearing
is a comparison to you my favorite
person ever Joey Diaz everybody keeps
saying you're a female Joey Diaz which
is there's no better description for a
comedian that exists in my what I mean
we shaped alike both our daddy left us
yeah we similar yeah and you both don't
give a fuck I don't give a fuck about
shit life is too short to give a fuck it
is too short I got four kids and two
abortions I don't give a fuck you can't
keep them all yeah you can't keep them
all there's times to do things in time -
not exactly it's a hot topic that's a
that's a fucking it takes the air out of
the room just fear it feel that dare you
how dare you implicate us in illegal
drug hey I'm gonna have all the soccer
moms callin riding me how dare you bitch
that was 20 years ago
Carl Jesus don't call me leave me the
fuck alone they wouldn't say how dare
you if you were white they might Oh a
lot of those Republican soccer moms that
are really anti-abortion
yeah you never see black people outside
of abortion clinic like girlfriend I
feel you I feel you my appointment next
week bitch there's a weird vacancy of
their eyes if you ever go to like a or
watch a documentary on those people like
I've seen those people if you there was
a Planned Parenthood I think it was in
Boston and I remember seeing these
people outside of it and they would
would you drive by and they would hold
up pictures of like dead babies and
stuff like hold up like that and they
harass women as they're going in they
like show them these pictures but when
they come out nobody is out there yeah
have you noticed that everybody's gone
yeah why is that I don't fucking know
they probably know when the time when
they were nobody was right there when I
went no I went they're not gonna protest
in the head they don't gonna fuck about
those babies you don't have to you don't
have that problem you just have the
problem getting a daddy they drop you
off you don't want to be a part of it
abortions tricky subject man you know
cuz it's like at what point in time
should it be okay like everybody kind of
is your choice absolutely ours
I always say this is my pussy I do what
I want that's why I say to you nobody
listens yeah you can do whatever you
want
who is Congress to tell you what to do
with yourself yeah no no no one can tell
you yeah because why is you happening
you can't take guys to kids when I was
fifteen what the fuck was you Dan
Congress you got two kids might over 15
yeah
that's crazy two kids Wow I have a
fucking childhood that is incredible I
don't know how I made it it was
incredible Wow
well you obviously made it you're okay
you're funny
yeah but I took I went through a lot of
shit to get funny Christ wasn't funny
when I was having them jacket on man
yeah old were you in you and your first
case I was 14 when I had my first kid by
merit man I met him when I was 12 and he
was 22 whoa so we started dating I was
in elementary school oh my god
well I had a really nice body I was
fuckable I might not be fuckable today
Joe but I was fuckable bag dear when she
start fucking twelve he was the first
one first one Wow he was the first one
you got a baby with him and you had a
baby when you're 14
- but and I did I got pregnant again and
gave birth when I was 15 oh my goodness
wow that is a crate where it was you
never met a teenage mom oh I've met
teenage well I'm an old teenage mom I
used to be a teenage mom that's just uh
it's it's hard for someone who has
children especially someone was
daughters like now I got two daughters -
yeah they didn't have any kids
they didn't have the life on it not in
play that shit what do they feel like
when they hear your story that's got to
be hard I mean I guess you'd have to ask
them but that has to be crazy to hear
that your mom went through that well my
daughter was there you know she was
there cuz I mean I got pregnant and
fourteen and I had a brother then I
couldn't get a job I started selling
drugs so she was there through
everything I mean I think I'm her hero
Wow so she got married and I
straightened everything out you know she
had a better life but you know that's
one of those situations where people
that have that attitude like that
everyone on welfare is just just lazy
like that people don't need a help they
do they need to pull themselves up by
their bootstraps like stories like that
man you gotta shut the fuck up Ronnie so
tastic let me tell you something when
you were you dealing with you like I
grew up in the ghetto my mom was on
welfare her mom was on welfare so people
I tell a story about welfare is like
diabetes if the mama get it there's a
good chance the daughter might get it so
you teaches I mean she taught me how to
do this shit and I just said I don't
want my daughter to go through this
bullshit I don't want my daughter to be
a teenage mom and you don't drop out of
high school my daughter is the first one
that graduated high school in three
generations and the first one to ever go
to college in my family Wow so I was
determined you are not gonna end up like
I ended up that's beautiful that's
amazing that that to me is the greatest
form of success ever
if you can learn from your own mistakes
import and part your life's wisdom on
your children and then your children go
on to take the ball and carry it and run
it further and do what you just said
become the first person to go to college
become the first person graduate high
school and many generations that's
beautiful that's yeah that's an amazing
thing congratulations
well thank you I mean I worked hard for
this year because I mean I didn't
graduate much nobody else I had nobody
to look up to I just know I was like my
daughter would not go through this
bullshit that I went through in life and
I had a son - so he graduated - but Wow
nobody else I mean how the kneestr
because i custody of my sister for kids
so hurt oldest daughter graduate cuz
they're the same age right after my
daughter did but nobody else everybody
just keep having babies and dropping out
it's so fuckin what do you call it
epidemic yeah you know it's just keep
passing it now yeah yeah it's um
there's definitely kids everybody learns
from their atmosphere that's why I
always tell people if you can surround
yourself with people that are trying to
get their shit together and we'll help
you get your shit together because you
you force yourself to the standard of
the people that you're around if you're
around a bunch of people that are real
friendly you're more likely to be
friendly you know if you around a bunch
of people that'll go out of the way to
help people you're more likely to go
away to help people and that's what I
did I started to surround myself I said
for me to do better I need somebody I
can learn from cuz I didn't learn shit
from my mama my mama stayed drunk all
the time and you know I was raised in a
bootleg house so all I saw was drunk
people just bullshit all my life so I
started to pick my girlfriend's if you
didn't have a college degree a high
school diploma you couldn't be my fuckin
freak because I have a bunch of stupid
asthma I need somebody I can learn you
know this is we put a correct sentence
together all that bullshit cuz I've
dropped out of school in eighth grade so
I needed to surround myself around
better people so all my girlfriend's got
college degrees and you know they
married they you know that's amazing
though you figured that out like how old
were you when you decided to have these
like really high standards um probably
about 17 cuz probably about 17 when
thing was winding down from being a bad
relationship with my kid's father
because you know I I started
dating him and I think what I was
looking for was just somebody to love me
cuz my I didn't have a fucking father so
I think I was just saying I need
somebody to love me so I get involved
this guy become very abusive who shoots
me he who beats me and then I'm thinking
you know cuz I was taught this my momma
said if a man don't hit you he don't
love you she said fuck yeah he hit me
with a roller skate one night this is
like the worst advice I've ever known
give me a lot of fucked up advice that I
realize now that was fucked up advice
but it was passed down to her so she was
like if a man no hit you he don't love
you so like my baby daddy hit me with a
roller skate one night because it's fool
love the roller skate and that fucking
skate shook my skull and I say to myself
at this love bitch I can do without it I
bought up my face and I knock that
motherfucker in the backseat and I
started to fight back from that day on
he shot me in the back of the hand not
to see me shoot you with a 38 Jesus
Christ where'd you hit you and it just
it cracked the back of my skull that's
it just grazed you now I went in a
little bit but it was fucked up cuz I
did it was like I can't believe you not
dead so I was in a hospital I get better
and I call him it's like oh you love me
come get me
that's how fucking he wasn't in jail you
didn't call no I wouldn't tell I was in
love cuz my momma say if I don't slap
you a couple times you know so he shoot
you oh my god that's real fucking love
Jesus Christ he was trying to kill you
what'd he say he wasn't
I was just that good you know how
fucking good and you have to be to shoot
somebody in the head and not care when I
was 15 oh my god you shot you in the
head when you were 15 holy shit I
totally get shot again in the titty what
the same shot you who shot you in the
breast a fucking fool in a drive-by blue
Manila all oh my God where were you
sitting when this happened no we was
arguing we had an argument so I put my
pissed in his face cuz I was a drug deal
I was like get the fuck out of here
before I shoot you but I'm just 15 with
a gun I didn't know you wasn't supposed
to pull a girl is she gonna shoot a
motherfucker so he come back with a 45
and started fucking pop pop pop up out
so I started running
one of the 45s heat me up out of the arm
and blew my whole fucking titty apart oh
my it was like stepping on a lime I see
and you were 15 yeah and you were 15
with two kids you got shot at I'm
daughter was with me when when he shot
me she sure was she was with me and when
they when they came to get me she was
like the police like what wasn't what
happened rabbit because that was my drug
bill alike and I didn't really want to
tell cuz I was like we don't kill this
motherfucker my daughter yellow
well monk monk shot my mama my mama put
a pill said monk face so he came back he
shot I'm like shut the fuck up you go
get me arrested Wow oh my god and that
you're 15 and how old was your daughter
then she - yeah Wow
yeah she's - she does know what the fuck
she's talking about she knew everything
fuck it she still remember to this day
because an insane environment to grow up
in it was my mom as a 15 year old drug
dealer who got shot in the titty yeah in
a drive-by yeah and you saw my with dope
and money like crazy every day how did
you not get did you get arrested fuck
yeah you always get arrested
always always lets no bean it they wait
til you earn enough money so they can
take it so an album yeah I did a year in
prison for it
that was the worst day of my life cuz I
miss my daughter going to kindergarten
you can't get that shit back right but I
was just trying to survive honestly I
was just trying to survive well I
couldn't imagine how anybody would
function just being 14 have a defend for
yourself having kids like what you can't
I couldn't because I was 15 and I needed
a work permit so a lot of times I would
just show up on the fucking interview
and it was like way your work for me I
was like meet Ashley and I kill I need a
fucking job I got two kids there's like
you're supposed to be in school that's
here not there I got two fucking kids to
fend for so at that time Craig had just
hit the black community really hard so I
started to sell Craig because everybody
was getting on him Wow
did you take it I never did drugs I grew
up watching my mama um as an alcoholic
so everything my mama did I said I
wouldn't do she smoked cigarettes she
drank she did whatever I was like I'm
not gonna end up like you motherfuckers
I think y'all stole me
well you were the the end of the line
you know I mean that's that it that's
what it looks like I mean looks like
you're the one who figured it out and
then you're imparting that onto your
kids but the end of the line like
sometimes enough is enough and enough is
enough your own genetics will like stop
cut the bullshit that's let's reset this
whole thing yeah good for you
especially when I keep my keys can't
grow on this bush how'd you start doing
stand-up um I went to the welfare office
you know to get my food stamps on
welfare recertified so you like it a
white caseworker and I tell her oh it's
such a whole life I've been shot I've
been this I've been that and you know
white caseworker once I tell these
stories in the detail white women
they're so easy to make cry so this
bitch to give me a few h2 bumps and tell
me what was going on free so one day I
go in and I got this black caseworker so
I said oh this bitch is gonna be hard
because you know you think all black
people's from the ghetto so I started
telling her these stories in this bitch
busts out laughing and I was like what
the fuck are you laughing at she's like
you should be a comedian this shit is
hilarious you ever heard of Richard
Pryor
these are Richard Pryor stole that's
like I didn't come here for no fucking
job I came for free shit
that's hilarious you didn't want a job
no I was on welfare I mean at the time I
was trying to get my life back together
so I'm you know I'm just home had a free
house cuz I Section eight cuz they're my
sister four kids so I had a total of six
kids and a husband who was working I was
like you know this how I grew up
motherfuckers standing home watching The
Young and the Restless so you didn't
even start to think about doing stand-up
until this lady brought that up when she
too first want to kind of put it in my
ear yell I never thought this shit was
funny it was pain see what I mean you
know I mean when you tell when I tell
these stories I had to get over them so
you got to forgive and then you gotta
you know you got to let everything go so
it doesn't bother you to tell it on
stage I can laugh about it now you know
people look at me having you know
sleeping with a married man I'm 12 and
he's 22
that's fuckin child molestation but how
do you deal with it so I deal with it I
laugh about it I'm turning
all that were you say and I used to be
pissed off at his do because he took my
fucking child I mean think about it I
was a mom at 14 that's crazy
I got a 16 year old daughter that all
she do is fucking play with her iPad it
just doing with a 16 year old supposed
to do I never had that opportunity I
never had an opportunity to build a girl
it's overrated because it was awesome
shit right now you know every song I
wish I was seven again I was retarded
when I was seven I'd be playing with
Mutant Ninja Turtles and pretend
pretending helicopters are real or
plastic helicopters that's stupid that's
stupid shit
I'm glad no you're not you know you
don't know I still your daughter Charlie
fucking be dropped kicking the shit out
that old need to get y'all ass away from
here you ain't get no pussy mother fuck
this cat what is it about a guy that
would want to do that that's what's
fucked up ain't like but you were
talking about like the whole patterns
you know ink your family falls into a
pattern I bet they're in this my mama my
my learned cuz I'm writing a one-woman
show for my for my life and I learned
that my daddy got my mama young like
that mmm
my mama had six kids by the time she was
22 so it's just passing it down yeah
it's so common that that happens on both
sides you know I mean maybe maybe you're
a husband or the man who gave got you
pregnant maybe like in his that isn't
that my fucking husband the dude baby
day whatever he was at the time he was
never your husband in 82 point I know he
was married
oh that's Wow well whoever he is I got
Facebook friends bet huh I bet you know
in his life I bet that was probably
common to you know I bet that kind of
fucked-up behavior was well yeah yeah
because I mean if you look at it is
child molestation for sure so to me he's
a fucking molester you know we learned
later we did all the shit but I mean to
fuck a 12 year old 22 and show up at the
hospital and sign both kids birth
certificate nobody questioned your own
Laius that's that is the most gross shit
out of all of these I cannot look at
Mikey's birth certificate
it because on there I'm 14 and he's 22
and my daughter went to get her birth
certificate cuz she was going on the
cruise and she was like oh my god look
this is nasty I was like bitch put that
away
I didn't say bitch but I was like wow
yeah it's a sickness it has to be this
it's and it's a sickness of the mind and
apparently when someone when it gets
done to them it's more likely that
they're gonna do it to somebody else
yeah and you know he never thought he
did anything wrong cuz I X and I was
like you know I'm in my 40s now you
actually took my childhood and he was
like your mind and body wasn't 12 what
the fuck are you talking about my mind
anybody cuz I had a big booty that was
around and my titties set up like apples
oh I had a cum fucked me sign on my
forehead well that's his way of excusing
his behavior he got horny when he was
around you so he felt like your body and
mind but you know when you describe it
see how was a man supposed to decipher
that if he's a dumb dude at 22 you know
he's not gonna decide for that now he
just wants to fuck yeah that's the
problem and though it's such an
overwhelming urge unless you have
someone around you constantly imparting
morals and ethics and growing you the
right way we grow up like animals we
have instincts you know
yes animal instincts horny instincts
they overcome any idea of guilt or
remorse or and so that's his way of
rational you know rationalizing it like
your body and mind weren't 14 well my
body truly was finest fuck I'm not
excusing him but I'm assuming he's a
dumb dude right he's dumb as fuck
he worked at jiffy lubes now nothing
wrong with people working at Jiffy Lube
but I hear you it's just it's it's hard
to get your shit together you know but
you getting your shit together in your
situation that's more impressive than
anybody any normal person in any other
situation because your situation sounds
so fucking crazy that for you to go full
circle from that to be in a working
professional comedian paying taxes the
whole deal I'm out and on top of that
the most important thing seeing your
kids grow up in a completely different
way
completely I tell my kids all the time
you don't know how fucking get you
average especially my second my second
to buy my husband you know we live in
the suburbs and they don't know she they
don't hear gunfire I never had to put
drugs and they pampers and called a dope
and sell drugs in front of their schools
I never had to do none of that shit to
them so I was like you don't know how
fucking good you got it yeah a lot of
people don't you know that's what that
the old expression you know that or the
old thought rather that one day there's
gonna come a point in time when the
apocalypse comes and then civilization
is gonna crumble apocalypse is already
here it's just not in your neighborhood
like there's spots in the world we can
go to right now where you might as well
be in Mad Max right there's how about
Liberia you hear this shit man they're
fuckin closing the borders of Liberia
because Ebola is breaking out and people
had it they escaped from the hospital
these fucking people escaped from
quarantine Jesus Christ they don't know
where they're going
it's a city of a million people wasn't
there somebody here in Los Angeles that
just xscape from the hospital also with
some kind of really contagious disease
and they were like here's a warrant for
his arrest right now because he just
left the hospital did he take the Kirwin
on that was that movie the strain I
think you were probably stoned in your
water stream that FX show have you seen
the strain no good fucking show man I
read the book and I didn't like it I
liked it for three-quarters of the way
but the last quarter was kind of wack
and I decided that that's not enough you
know three-chord is really good and then
1/4 the book sucks I can't recommend it
but as a show it's awesome
it's really cool that's just I think
that's what they were meant and they
meant to do when they made this tray in
the first place they meant to make it as
a miniseries and they wrote it as a book
but that that's how it takes place it
takes place that they're a disease
there's a quarantine and these people
get out and then then everyone's fucked
I don't like to get out of me but I'm
just going listen to you we're talking
about the apocalypse talking about
terrible situation
why Quentin Sean that's it you were 15
you had your baby with you and you drug
deal and all that if you forced some
white woman in her for
yeah into that situation she would be
means our fucking that would be the
apocalypse there'll be the apocalypse
for her I have to sell crack what
someone shot my tit off what I can't do
this you know I mean that would be just
like the apocalypse there'd be no
different would be I found it it's act
it was actually in North Hollywood it
was a guy with tuberculosis tuberculosis
is that super contagious if we give bad
I think it's something that you like if
he starts sneezing this yeah I think
they arrested him oh okay
yeah but they could treat tuberculosis
right that's not scaring me like Ebola
Ebola is a hemorrhagic virus which means
you bleed you bleed everywhere like you
but your eyeballs bleed your fucking
skin falls apart like Ebola is rough
business that's no joke those
hemorrhagic viruses when I did that
sci-fi show questions everything the the
real issue with it was like the scary on
that show was talking about infectious
diseases and they were talking about you
know everybody's worried that like
there'll be some terrorists and then
released some anthrax and everybody get
fucked they like listen what nature
makes the stuff that nature's making
that is way scarier than any fucking
shit that anybody's cooking up in a lab
because at any given point in time
nature can make some insane virus that
no one can fix at any point in time
these two viruses can interact with each
other and create some mutant and it can
they're constantly changing and growing
and they're constantly avoiding the
attack by antibiotics and and antiviral
drugs so they're strengthening and
getting stronger and in finding new
trickier ways to get into people's
bodies
you scare me can we just stay the fuck
out of me he scared the fuck out of me
one of these dudes was a Russian cat who
told me that when the Cold War was going
on they had trenches filled with anthrax
trenches and I go how many people would
that kill he said every person on the
planet every single person I said
there's enough anthrax to kill every
person but he was absolutely no question
about it there's enough anthrax that
had that could kill everybody what are
you talking about
how much anthrax is there I don't Lee
takes like a little bit to kill you like
anthrax is a motherfucker and this idea
was that they were gonna figure out some
sort of an airborne dispersion method
and even the government even tested like
there was something I think it was in
Cleveland I forget the city but they
sprayed some shit over this city like
phosphorescent like something that they
could track they like essentially what
the chemtrail people think is going on
you know like they actually did it and
they did it from the top of a building
they sprayed it or something like that
because they were trying to figure out
how much of a containment period how
much of an area would they have to
contain you know if a disease got out
that's how goofy people are they were
thinking about like actually just it's
so indiscriminately just letting a
disease go out a dizzy like that was an
option like a disease that would kill
the entire part not just the soldiers
not just the people that were you know
the politicians who were causing the war
in the first place no the entire
population with a virus a virus and make
your fucking eyeballs bleed out I think
you just scared the shit out of us you
know why I think we should scared
because look if the world was just us we
would work everything out you know yeah
I couldn't imagine going to war with you
miss Pratt you seem like a very nice
person but I don't mean it like that I
mean you know I'm saying if there was
some if you had a country that you owned
that I had a country that I think we
could come to some reasonable terms I
don't think it would be an issue but
when you see shit like what's going on
in Israel today you see these you know
Israel's got they've got all their
military troops there and there
everyone's launching rockets and it's
just horrifying man you seeing babies
that are dead on the beach these photos
Anthony Bourdain tweeted some photo the
other day it was horrifying
like why if that can happen over there
that can happen right fucking here
I mean it's contained while it's over
there and our idea is that well if it's
out of there if it's out of our mind but
that shit's going on right now in 2014
and it could just as easily happen in
New York or in Pittsburgh or anywhere
anywhere just pick a city London that
can happen in London crazy shit can go
down like that
any part of the world if you've got
enough people that disagree and they're
highly armed and they have religious
ideas attached to what they're doing
you got a terrifying situation that's
how we're living right now in 2014 I saw
the worst video over the weekend on
Facebook for some reason Facebook has
the worst videos now people are posting
on their lines but one is this Israeli
family that captured a child from
Palestine and kid was probably like 5 or
6 and they're teaching their daughter
who is Jewish I guess or whatever
israelian I to beat the kid with a bat
and so the kids like crap please stop
you know this look five-year-old and
this little six-year-olds hitting it
with a bat and she wouldn't she didn't
want to hit it hard you know she's just
barely hitting it and this other kid
that's a little order comes up no but
there's no hate um and just like starts
punching this little kid in the face
because the kids bouncing yeah yeah they
like captured somebody and they're just
beating this kid up like the whole
family like the kids everyone oh can we
go back to the ghetto Eddie Bravo and I
we watched that movie once what is that
fucking movie is a Brazilian movie about
the the ghetto Oh children of God city
of God yes City of God City of God it's
all fucking crazy move you ever seen it
no god damn this Pat you gotta see City
of God it's incredible it's really
really really fucking good but it's all
about the favelas of Brazil and how the
violence there is just on a completely
different level
first of all these houses are
essentially like a lot of them are
almost like they're camping out like
they don't have windows then I'm running
water they have dirt floors and some of
them you know there's like some of them
they can range in you know like ghetto -
incredibly poor like essentially you
live in the woods and you just have like
a shelter around it's not much different
than that and these young kid drug
dealers just unbelievably violent and
ruthless the whole movies just like
soukra more people die in the first five
minutes of that movie than the entire
boys in the hood damn
yeah like quickly like more people die
maybe in the first five minutes it's a
but it's a good fucking movie - and it's
based on a real scenario if
you you go to the ghettos of Brazil like
some of the worst poor neighborhoods
where there's a lot of drug violence
that was what they were scared of when
it came to the World Cup you know that's
really some horrifying shit can't be
going down there that's happening right
now so I use always somebody's got it
worse that's how fucked up people are
this just a huge range of what we're
capable of you know so when people see
fucked up shit that's going on in the
news and they try to pretend it's not
happening right now because it's on the
other side of the world that's like yeah
well if it's possible right now
somewhere it's possible here you know
just a bunch of things would have to go
wrong and it could be just as possible
here well let's hope it don't make it
here we just gotta figure out a way to
get better people to lead the world it's
that simple
it's really that simple that is the 100%
solution for all of it yeah there's a
lot of problems financially there's a
lot of problems in this world as far as
politically the different sides like
like the the argument like you know I'm
not a I'm not a Republican by any
stretch of the imagination
but I believe in some things that they
think make sense I'm a big Democrat but
I do believe in a lot of stuff that they
say yeah well I think the Democrats what
I like socially the attitude of the
Democrats better I think it's a more
progressive attitude as far as caring
for people and looking after people and
sometimes people point down at that and
they say you know the accuse people of
facilitating the welfare state and they
have all these goofy ideas about like
what it is that keeps someone in a bad
situation like that that's the number
one problem that I have with right-wing
people this is pull them up by their
bootstraps mentality cuz I'll meet
someone like you I'm gonna go what
fuckin bootstraps she's a fucking 14
years old and she's got a baby you
telling to babies yeah - well another
one we 15 you're telling me that she
should be pulling herself up by her
bootstraps that's fucking crazy I don't
know other than what you did though
other than what you did personally where
you just realized that fucking enough is
enough you worked hard you got yourself
out of that situation how else you been
through it it would if you cut how to
engineer the way our society fixes this
problem that we have with it so you
gotta what me I had to somebody had to
make
we realized there was a problem which
when I got married I met him when I met
my husband he was like people don't live
like this and I was like what do you
mean people don't live like this
he's like people go out and get a job
people don't take from other people
people don't sell drugs so I had to be
taught that from my husband that's crazy
you know and I'm here I am 1:19 I think
at the time and I had to go get a job
how do you go how do you go into society
and get a fucking minimum-wage job when
you used to making $10,000 a day as you
know when you 16 and 17 years old
$10,000 a day yes I had a fucking trap
out of this world
I mean I don't want to call a trap I
don't know what they call it now because
I've been going from the ghetto too long
but back then it was called a trap so
when you're selling drugs like your
neighborhoods attracted yeah you stand
on the corner that's your a trap if
that's why you start the crackheads or
the junkies to calm then that's why they
came and everybody knew rabbit was on
fast rate Oh rabbit was on fast treat
that's her trap a thirst trap we need to
start call our shows traps
oh yeah we do a trap this weekend the
ice house no use that term anymore cuz I
don't know what you do to sell drugs
anymore if they didn't use it on the
wire people haven't heard it no that was
desperate because it was I think the
wire was a little after I study said
probably written by white people too but
you know what that show fucking husband
I love this show
and I was like he was like you gotta see
this show and when I saw I don't want to
see that flash shit I don't want to
relive that crap yeah and I got into
night you know watching the whole
fucking I'll love it and he was like how
real is it cuz my husband come from a
background where mama go to church every
day any day to go to work every day and
it was 16 with them but they wasn't on
welfare and daddy and Mama provided for
them where I didn't have that life
you're not hooked right you know his
mama and play that shit you weren't
selling drugs you wouldn't run in the
street you was going to school Wow so
you know so did he like when when he met
you and you said nobody lives like this
did he offer suggestions or do you just
take you by the hand listen bitch we're
gonna straighten this shit pretty much
he was just
like you know he I think he was he was
attracted cuz I was a go-getter cuz I
was I was I was coming out of selling
drugs go people had you know the crack
epidemic was forging checks so I was I
was into that shit really heavy he was
like you heard me give all over fuckin
know these people
Bank of America and check number his
high you know he's like you can't do
this shit and he just talked to me and I
would listen I remember I had a lot of
drugs one day and he was like I like you
and I want to date you he said but I
can't take you home and my mom as a drug
dealer and your name is rabbit so I'm
thinking this is an opportunity for my
kids to have a daddy and he got all his
back teeth any can read and his shoes
clean and he don't punch a bitch in the
eye every Friday ching ching I had to
have him
that's hilarious Wow so I went for that
so I gave my niece who I taught how to
sell drugs all of my drugs so she did
she work for you or did you see her the
business what she was young when I got
her she was like maybe ten and they will
haul the drugs for me over the years so
I you know I told her how to do it and
she became a drug deal when did she
start selling drugs for you she it was
probably 11 oh my god we was all fuckin
kids cuz they mom was on crack mm-hmm
this is my this is my baby daddy's
sister their mom was on crack so I took
them me Here I am she think they're 11
and I'm fuckin 15 they thinking I'm
grown ain't growing off shit so now I
got my two kids and her three kids and
we live in I'm taking everybody to
school cuz I saw drugs in front of my
door my door to school this was before
the no school no drug school zone signs
went up so I was already grandfathered
in when that she got there that's a
really serious federal federal offense
right if you sell drug yeah hose to a
school yeah but I was already growing
them size wasn't not making those days
so I would drop everybody off at school
and everybody
when they got out they knew what to do
with the drugs right wow that is crazy
so you just had a whole system going I
had a whole system going so when you
decided you meet your husband you say
you know what all right this dude's
great I'm gonna listen to him I'm gonna
do whatever I have to do to keep this
work and I'll just have her take care of
this does she are you telling what to do
is she an employee I just give it so I
say you can have the whole trap I'm
gonna give this dude a chance and it was
weird because I had no more money I
couldn't ride around in my flashy
Cadillac anymore yeah because I hadn't
learned his license and what alone is
like you need a fucking kid you need a
licensed driver so our high a crackhead
for a day different crack is hey you got
a driver's license in the car I'm gonna
supply you a you know crack every hour I
just need the police pull pull out your
fucking license so I can drive with my
learner's like it that's not I learn how
to drive a crack it taught me how to
drive that is crazy so you're driving
crackheads around just so that you could
drive they that enabled you to do your
business yes to drop off dope pick up no
would think the crackheads would go this
chick is fucking 15 and she just ran
shit they was they was scared of me how
did you have your shit together like
that at 15 we live you know what my
husband tell me he said it it has a lot
to do with my granddaddy my granddaddy
used to sell
buuut he was a bootleg look I mean
bootleg liquor bootleg house whatever
you call it so he said I never saw
anybody work in my family everybody
hustle so I guess I got those skills
from him it makes sense if you grew up
seeing something like that I think
that's how people are supposed to live
and everybody thought I was grown Joe
nobody knew I was fucking 15 I mean I
had two kids and other kids selling
drugs for me and everybody was like yes
ma'am no ma'am and one day they was like
how old are you and I said six days like
you fucking 16 I had like eight cars a
learner's wife who's completed crack yes
they were hey baby hey rabbit you want
me to drive for you
you were right in the car and I would
just apply them rocks and they smoked
the rock when I'm riding around with Run
DMC and whoever was out at the time you
know Invo pumping my visa are they
smoking crack because I needed a
licensed driver in the car is so crazy
no how old were you when you got popped
um you know what I had a police officer
beer he said he said I know you selling
crack bitch he said but I'm not gonna
lock you up until you seventeen cuz when
this crack first hit the black community
everybody went to jail at 18 you went to
juvenile at 17 but people just go down
there yo your kids get caught with a
fuckin half a key of cocaine and you can
get them right out of juvenile cuz they
didn't really know how to handle the
situation so they changed the age from
18 and 17 yo let's go to jail at 17 in
Georgia so I had a birthday April the
second that fucker had me in jail April
of feel free to seek some shit like that
I had a cousin that in the morning
everybody went to school they set up my
cousin so my cousin I would drop or I'll
say hey sell this and I be right back on
part of the car so crackhead was like
rabbit the police is up up on the hill
on the ground laying down before I could
make it back to pick up my cousin she
was like 15 he went down there and
fucking arrested her and took her to
where she hid the drugs at and so he it
shouldn't weren't for me so I couldn't
say with know yet being on the heel
taking pictures all day I mean all
morning so that's how I got my first
drug charge so how long did you go away
for oh I didn't go away then I got
probation and then I got popped again
and then I went I was in jail a year so
when you got probation did you have any
like idea of like okay I could get
caught for this really easy business no
I was like fucking I thought I was
fucking Al Capone I was untouchable
I have money it's like fuck you I'll be
out in no time and back then when you
first went to jail like I told you they
used to give you buns but they stopped
giving you buns so I remember I needed I
had to have a bun here so I had to pay
for the judge in Atlanta to have fucking
dancers and he gave me a $2,500 bond and
I was out they have no answers what do
you mean Paisley is holes you know what
who
the judge you paid for the judges
prostitutes hos there was there was
having a party okay so my lawyer was
like you gotta put in a few extra money
he's gonna give you a bond but you got
to put in a few extra money so I put in
extra money pay for the holes and they
gave me a twenty five thousand dollar
bond I cut my friend frog who I was
selling drugs with at the time cuz we
was partners like come fuckin give me so
the judge went and took your money and
got prostitutes yeah that's hilarious ad
but that's what the lawyer you know
that's what lawyer said yeah verify that
that's one of those things they like
people would know about there's a judge
that everybody was cricket Baghdad oh my
god crooked that's that's a bad position
to put a person in do you remember the
judges name was a judge Matthews no
judges oh yeah there's something about
being a judge and I think it's an
unhealthy position I don't think anybody
should have that kind of power or
someone like to decide to send someone
to jail to not send someone to jail send
someone to jail for 30 days or 90 days
or I just don't I just think that that
kind of power I think there should be
rules most certainly but I think that
kind of power bestowed upon a person to
make that sort of a decision their own
discretion is just it's too much it's
too much responsibility you can't trust
someone to be totally ethical and not
fucking crazy and people change too they
get more crazy as they get older and
they get more crazy with ego you know
yeah people get nutty there's a lot of
nutty people they get a little bit of
attention and then they just fucking go
off the deep end go off the deep end
believe their own bullshit and if you're
a judge everyone's kissing your ass all
day all day but you wear the robes you
come in the Honourable they fucking
everybody has to rise when you come into
the room what kind of shit is that
everybody else has to stand up because
you're here and they call you the
Honorable get the fuck out of here there
was a guy they busted recently was using
a penis pump while he was while he was
presiding over cases he had on his part
this is walking he's pop up his penis
I'm sitting there talking to people and
under
meet the table he's jerking himself off
with a giant tube and a pump like what
are you doing man and the foot went flat
just a guy is just a guy no one deserves
to be a judge no one you can't be a
judge you can't be the king either by
the way can't be a president that shit
was for dumb people that didn't know any
better we in 2014 with the information
that we have today we needed Google all
we need is let people vote on shit okay
let the entire country vote on every
goddamn thing that gets done ever you
can't have one person that has any over
oversight or power over everybody else
anything you know I mean I don't know
how you would do it as far as like cases
as far as like prosecuting people I
don't know how you would do it without a
judge but it's got to be a better you
ever been to jail no it's a horrible
thing the food is horrible when I was a
little kid and they closed the cell and
they leave you in there for about five
seconds
San Francisco so every time I go he's
like you want to visit a cat ray I was
like look you dumb fuck you don't act a
convicted felon do they want to give
volunteering visa fucking old jail no I
don't wanna visit Alcatraz I've been to
jail before I know what it looked like
there's something also about people to
go to jail it's a lot like people that
have been to war or people that have
gotten over some a very traumatic event
is that they have a certain kind of
strength there's a certain kind of
strength that a person has when they
they're the people that decide like I am
fucking never going back there like well
yeah some people like I got some
brothers that been in and out of jail
are they fucking like some people like
going back my brother-in-law's do for me
when I miss my daughter going to
kindergarten I'm doing a year in jail
that totally fucked me up and I you know
my meet by me having that lifestyle not
really nothing that I chose but what I
went through I did not have a bond with
my daughter Joe for years and I don't I
don't know if you have any kids but when
you have a kid that deeply probably
hates you
for the life that you chose you know to
help her she didn't realize I was doing
this shit
so I could make better for you you know
me missing school and meet me missing
her go to Kitty gun and you know me
selling drugs and hurting people me my
daughter did not have a fucking mind
for a long long time so when I brought
my husband into her life she immediately
bond with him but I was always the bad
person
Wow well she probably looked at him as
like the savior he was a savior he
wasn't said she has a bun out of his
work now we talk every day
and you know another thing is when I
went to prison
then I I got out and I really fucking
hate him and I hate to say this that's
your punk ass so fucking be hope you
don't take it the wrong way I hate it
game women I don't know I could deal
with gay means but I saw so much other
than shit in jail now I've never been
with a woman nobody fuck with me cuz I
filed out of time
but I just hated this shit and then when
it when it came into my life my daughter
is gay I was like oh fuck how stupid am
I you can't deal you can't judge people
on asexuality so all doing my when I was
raising my daughter oh she always ended
up getting a gay fucking Chilean coach
and I hated this bitch and my daughter
no I hated gay women's so what my
daughter was gay so that's another thing
that did not allow her to bond with me
because she knew my hatred for gay women
wow that's intense
oh shit so would answer me this weekend
what do you think it is about the black
community that shuns gay people or shuns
like gay marriage because that was like
a big issue in California here they had
Proposition 8
prop 8 is that what it is the Bible it's
religion yeah you know black people
believe no matter what they believe it's
a god you know we're going to heaven or
hell
that's just how we talk and I think a
lot of that shit come from because our
ancestors were slaves and it just I
think it just rolled on through the
genes but we believe so that's what it
is yes but it seems it's sold in this
town 2014 you know it seems so
discriminatory when you see that people
are born gay well you know Java gay
daughter did I'm very supportive and I
don't feel that away and
it's almost like I'm a white doing his
door though to bring home a awake a
white goddaughter bring home a black
dude I mean you either gonna get over a
fucking jump off of a bridge and realize
that you the person that has the problem
not them and that's what I had to
realize you know because these bitches
will put in jail and I didn't like them
well these are not these are not that
gay people who my daughter is bringing
over so now is very fuckin supporter
whatever makes my daughter happy plus
you gotta remember Here I am 15 years
old getting fucking dogged out by her
daddy beat on shot on fuckin knocked
around cheated on you know she just saw
so fucking much that I think turn you
know fuckin like fuck me and some niggas
ain't right yeah so I think that there
was this part of the issue too she said
she was born gay I say in my fucking
room bitch the archer saw you was not
licking anything so I mean do I know I
don't know if she was born gay but she's
gay and I supported her decision to be
gay
that's my firstborn and I love the hell
out of her you know like when she first
came out cuz she when she went to
college she left town because she knew
how much I hated gay women's and I ain't
seen my own fuckin child for three years
I would try to contact her she was out
in the rural been homeless and I was
like what is your fucking problem what
is your problem I said if you get just
say you gay she said I'm gas but can you
come home bitch cuz I mean she been
three fucking years so and now we talk
every day we talk and I love the hell
out my daughter she got him I got a
wonderful daughter-in-law they looked
just like she look like Paula Paula no
but I've seen her so you know I'm a
supportive mom now I mean I love my
daughter I love my kids to death I have
four of them you know and we talked
about the shit that I taking her thing
from putting the drugs in their
underwear
- you know me dropping out of school she
was there with it but she must feel
different about you now
shit I'm not fucking around and she's
mine I mean because she did something
that I never had an opportunity to she
didn't get pregnant in high school she
didn't I mean she didn't she you know
she went on and graduated fine when she
graduated Joe I said I fucking made it I
thought it was nothing that you could've
killed me that day cuz you know why none
of my cousin kids graduated nobody else
my fucking Ashley is walking down this
aisle
I made it I couldn't stop crying and
she's like what are you crying I was
like if only you knew what I did to get
you to this point
you broke a fucking cycle that has been
going on in my family for three
generations
I didn't even cry like that when I took
her to college but boy when she
graduated high school I pick up that
diploma once a week and say bitch we
lady and a high school diploma bullshit
about it equal to my GED yeah today
right yeah even a college diploma it's
so hard you hear stories about people
getting out of college and looking for a
job now it's like it's so confusing it
is I mean it's hard I tell my kids on
time I made more money you could
probably ever do doing shit that you
really want to do cuz when you go to
college you going for you know you don't
really know what the fuck you wanna do
you want to go and get high and fuck the
first year that's all my god my daughter
went to college and I you know what I
pay for her tuition the whole three
years she was there that's because you
were not struggle do you know she went
to college and ate pussy on my dime she
ain't pussy on my time like crazy she's
trying to find herself
yes it's somebody else yourself losing
back teeth and shit I'm like you got to
stop eating pussy you got a blue shit
you lose your back teeth when you eat
bad pussy joke what defines bad I don't
know I can call my daughter
one faction oh no watch your gums I
don't know wait you know that is crazy
wow that's a hilarious story it's gotta
be a nice thing to be where you're at
now though yes I'm happy
how many been doing stand-up 11 years
I've been married 23 Wow so so 11 years
ago this this person at the welfare
office tells you should do stand-up so
what do you do from there I go home and
I told my husband I'm funny
he's like can you sit down and be quiet
so I said I'm gonna go to open mic he
was like don't pay my husband not the
type he's not gonna say don't do it
either whatever because I was in the
process he musta husband some ego from a
drug dealer to forging checks to fucking
I got a little vending service at the
Georgia done when Michael Vick first
became our our quarterback so I'm making
a ton of my money with inner-city kids
with a nonprofit organization so he's
telling me go from that and then all of
a sudden you want to be a stander he's
like how many time are you gonna change
your career I said I'm telling find
myself so I get my girlfriend which is a
long story short my baby's daddy baby
mama lived around the corner for me this
is a chickie show up at the hospital
after I give birth to his first child so
he we became best friends I swear we
still we raised the kids as cousins
because she had a baby bottom too so I
get her and I was like this case workers
say I'm funny let's go to open like and
I go up there Joe and I fucking killed
and I'm first time I told I told a story
about my brother was a UH profession a
cat burglar but he was fat so he kicked
this lady doing one time he's like
freeze bitch I'm the FBI give me a TV in
your VCR so he fear and not to go cuz he
broke at houses everyday and that was my
first joke that's hilarious
and so when you did that did you write
any shit out or you just I didn't know
cuz I grew up in I started in an urban
womb so I started to follow the
arbitrary I suck dick
I eat booty you know how other black
people do the shit you seen Def Jam so I
was like I look up and I got that
drug-dealing mentality I was like
well I'm not sticking out I'm doing
everything these motherfuckers doing and
I was like it's gotta be something
better here I'm not gonna make you $50 a
week they say how to dope gang work cuz
I everything is like the dope gain to me
it must elevate right and so when my
husband got a transfer to it was either
Detroit st. Louis or Indianapolis and I
was like you're not gonna kill my kids
in those other cities and he chose I
wanted to go to Texas so he chose
Indianapolis
so I walking out with his uh I walk into
a mainstream club at the time which was
more these and I got this urban flair
and it's like not here bitches we don't
do roaches jokes
so if forces jokes yeah roaches you know
how you see a black me yeah you ever had
a roach drink out your kool-aid oh I get
it you know in India then you got the
jokes about the government cheese and
shit so when I move to Indianapolis
things like you can't do that shit here
you know nobody gonna have fuckin
roaches what the fuck are you talking
about so it forced me to open up to my
life that I had which was way more
interesting wow so you were trying to
just do what everybody else was doing
and then going to this white
neighborhood go into the white
neighborhood when we moved fuck me up it
fucked me cuz I never been you know like
an every club did more D's in a nap in
yeah yeah and and it was a little black
owner at the time well he's in jail for
bank robbery last year with no girls you
just showed him all 32 of his cavities
get up whoo and I got two in Annapolis I
had to change who I was so I had to find
myself and I just started talking about
my life which which was you know kind of
embarrassing to kids at 15 dropped out
in eighth grade you know you think of
people gonna fucking I thought I was the
only teenage mom on a road I thought I
was only bitch and I am the only one
probably missing the nipple that's gonna
tell but all this stuff that happened to
me I thought it was just me did I learn
fuckin teenage pregnancy happened in
every race yeah well there's a whole
show on it yeah what the fuck was that
shit when I had my baby
you better off without it you better off
he'll be coming you and now yeah getting
famous you could handle it better yes so
when I got to Indianapolis shit change I
moved to a white neighborhood and I just
started to work on myself so do you
write like material or do you always
talk about your life like I write like
stuff about being mayor kids most of my
stuff is personal so I you know where
everybody gets it you know my life you
know been a drug dealer I talk a lot
about my mom who was an alcoholic mom
who used to give me the worst advice
like she would say shit like reach for
the stars and I hope you hit the Sun and
burn up so I I told my whole other day
my mom was so fucking stupid she was I'm
not gonna say she was stupid she didn't
know shit like she couldn't read so she
will force me to read her horoscope but
what she didn't know I couldn't read
either so I would just make up shit
every day I made a bullshit bullshit and
she went forward like I was saying cuz
she was shoot at us like she told her 22
pills stir because she was my mama was a
very small lady so she walked around at
22 pills she's carried it everywhere
oh yeah we're like we wouldn't watch
this pop out why some god damn dishes we
shoot it into the ceiling yes and when
it rained it showed so when it rained
water would come dripping through the
holes that she left by shooting the news
why don't fuck the ceiling leak cuz
bitch you don't put 22 of them holes in
his ceiling what the fuck are you
talking about Wow yeah that's a way to
motivate kids though and we get out of
her way out of her shit it on she never
pointed out oh she left but I'll just
shoot a light out Wow so damn but we got
used to like oh mama with this bullshit
did she ever shoot at you and she shot
at me one time I was on the phone with
my baby daddy
I was on the phone my baby that she's
like get the fuck out the phone so my
mom was like pre handicapped because we
live in the project and the
security-guard fucking body slammed and
fucked up her spine so she if you is she
sit down she couldn't get back up so we
we had to be there
so I knew I wanted to talk on the phone
my baby daddy's time I made this time
prating with my second child so my mom
was like get off the phone with that
motherfucker he's gonna get you pregnant
that's somebody else husband so I tell
my kids father I was like hold on why go
ahead and lay her there and she was only
like 98 pounds so I picked up and I
later in the bathroom on the floor I'm
like you stay right down so I get to
talking my baby daddy what I didn't know
Joe is that bitch could crawl she
crawled out that bathroom like military
style with that shotgun and shot at my
head I flew out the door she shot at you
with a shotgun what a shotgun she got it
like the closet she got it she shot at
you with a shotgun because you were on
the phone with a man and you put her on
the floor yeah I put it on the floor she
couldn't get up so I think if you don't
stop soon it'll fucking get you off the
floor oh my god so how did you guys
resolve that he ran out of bullets
what did she shoot you shoot just holes
in your house yeah she would just shoot
up anything we were gonna victim she was
like you would be watching the TV and
she would tell you to move she'll blow
the motherfuck out if you didn't move
really any time she shoot the TV just
once because we can't afford a novel
it's only two wanting it for the keys
and one for her how much material do you
think like I would say if you're gonna
become a big-name stand-up comedian
you're gonna have to put out a bunch of
specials right so if you put out how
many specials can you do on your life
before you have to start talking about
other shit probably four or five four
five specials cuz you know what a lot of
stuff that I remember like even so at a
time like I can laugh at an ambu-bag dad
it was pain so I didn't get on drugs
like my sister did I didn't my brother
Tim got on drugs to deal with bullshit
that we was going through I just say you
know sober and thought these
motherfucker was crazy
so to get rid of the pain I just kept
putting it in the back of my head I
didn't want to remember it so when I
became a comic all of this shit started
rushing through my brain and I have 2x
my sister bitch is this real
I just X my sister other day my
granddaddy ran a bootleg house so in
this bootleg house I had a retarded
uncle named uncle Cecil that was
crippled but my granddaddy would buy him
pussy on Friday but me and my
sister will help the going down with the
prostitute and hold his legs back until
he get his dick in before we could go
outside and play so I called her up and
I said is this shit real you know hold
his legs back cuz this is what crippled
you know how when they need know so he
couldn't he couldn't get it in until we
moved his fucking legs back I remember
what I was like am probably eight I was
like okay sister put it in his fucking
smile because he will retard ease I know
it's so fucking often IX my brother I
was like do y'all remember this shit I
am I'm going crazy and I look like come
on brother last week and I say my mama
used to had this theory she say wouldn't
when it rains and the sun is shining the
devil was beating his wife you've heard
us and she said we were rain and
lightning and the sunshine he called the
beast G oh she's my mom's like you
should be the bitch cuz she don't
believe in God talking about you crazy
bitch think they stole me Joe nobody to
this fuckin she's the irony in that
you know this God want you shooting your
fuckin Christ
she's like I can't hit you it I can pull
a trigger and we were scatter as for
years we were scatter well in her
defense probably very hard to raise a
bunch of kids what happened to her back
someone slammed her on her back okay we
lived in the projects she was the candy
lady so she my mom candy lady that's
when that's the lady in the hood they
said a free freeze pop the candy the
cookies to the kids and my mama did it
because we was in the projects and that
money helped her with her light bills or
whatever the fuck and she's a talk shit
to the security guard he's back for the
projects were really dangerous so the
security guard was like Mildred you you
cannot sell candy because it's fucking
aren't earned income and you not
reporting but he was just fuckin with
her because my mama talked a lot of crap
so she's like oh fuck you sucker
- God you ugly fake whatever she said so
he came at least imma come whoopee away
and I had to be about probably seven
that dude came in and beat the dog shit
I was into wrestling time he's in a DDT
and shit out before he came in the house
she gave me my sister - can she go flush
the shit he own the way so we're in the
bathroom poppin Pixy stick like cocaine
eating shit here and there whooping her
ass so he he hit her up against the wall
and fucked her spine up so she sued the
house and thought but she couldn't read
and the fucking lawyer took all the
money we got put out of the projects so
oh that's what that when they
demonstrate spire-like she could no
longer hold her neck up like if she be
talking that bitch fall over so she had
to keep us to keep her nikka while she
was driving oh my one incident with this
guy did that yes she was like 90 pounds
what happened to him I don't know I was
a kid I don't really know I remember
going to court and testified you know
you know I saw hard
I got great jokes about it you know she
would do shit she even though her nigga
fucked up she was determined to do
nominate people shit like go across shit
like go across the track too fast right
and one side she had a 64 Chevy that
used to bounce and she loved like old
music so we're not just bouncing listen
to BB King and she gonna beat the train
that bitch hit that first track in a net
went back she like Pittman a cop bitch
the train coming my sister slap the shit
out of her knee and it went through the
city poster with you know jump over the
seat and hold a nickel while she drive
across a tray she pull over
you bitches hit me too hard muscles
right mr. train was coming oh my god you
bitches hit you hard
holy shit so she could she could walk
and she could use her feet but she
couldn't use oh I know about that she
had a boyfriend but I hope she could
suck me because she never called him now
to pick her neck up is that what you
would draw the line I want to pick the
neck up I have my crip walk a fuck seems
like one more level
I mean not everything went I saw is
nothing that I did not see as a kid
money murder
fuck yeah I tell you before I tell you
about my son more murder when I was a
drug dealer
that's when I really saw murder but I
had a guy that lived in our backyard
well we lived some part minutes and this
is when heroin and she came out very
popular in the black community so my
next-door neighbor used to shoot up but
my mama used to shoot up too but it was
diabetic medication so I would walk out
there this y'all walk outside one day on
the back porch and I'm sitting there so
he shooter what I thought was diabetic
medication he get butt-ass naked y'all
run over to me
bend over he's like rabbit get the rent
out of my ass so I'm looking up this
dude asked for right and I'm like
jay-bez no ready the diabetes fucking up
I was like the red is hanging in the
front so he thought he got nichkhun
every weekend there's nobody said shit
you were telling him was his diabetes
medicine well that's what I thought it
was but it was it was heroin I learned
we learned later that he was shooting
arrow so it when he got naked on Friday
well like Jay badge is high he'd be all
right there's only one day he got naked
no he got naked every time he shot drugs
how many days a week did he shoot drugs
shit two three so two or three days a
week he was naked on some people care
some people can't like when he wasn't
you know he was a fucking he was all
engineer for a living an engineer like
he designed things yes that's what he
did for a living he got a hair on it
engineer like running a train no not
like that he designed shit
he was like fucking corporate America he
was a shit but he came to the ghetto and
got high and take off he felt so
embarrassed once his high came down Wow
and people would just let Jay Bell walk
around naked I wonder if that's like his
way of releasing all the stress of
keeping all wrapped up tightened in
corporate America no he's a she I think
he thinks stuff was crawling on him- Dee
Dee's ass and we blow Jay Bell just
naked he just
ask I before we moved in these boobs
before we moved in this set apartments I
will go to the wrestling match every
week when we moved in this will set up
apartments I stopped going cuz it was
nothing to see people fighting you know
motherfuckers like they're acting a fool
it was more interesting set on my back
porch and it was real wow that is crazy
that has got to be so bizarre be that
young you gotta pull one guy's legs
apart
no big fuck that no other guy that's
running around naked and he's on heroin
that was the norm when you in that
situation nothing else seems what you
doing the right shit is out of place
what I'm doing this is what I'm used to
you that's the weird thing about human
beings they're very adaptable you know
that's what they're saying about people
that live in any country watch tribal
people and you know why don't these
people don't have any TVs they don't
have any electricity like they don't
even know what that is like this is
normal to them you see people in those
villages they find in the Amazon and
they don't have any contact with human
beings we feel bad for them but what are
they doing they're just being people
being people that figured out how to
live there you know and you were a
person who figured out how to live in
your your wild world Wow Wow
that was a wild world I mean it might as
well just been the wild of the Amazon or
the wild of the forest or the wild of
the city it's just wild there's varying
degrees right yes this there's places
where shit is just wild and where you
were living
craziness so once you make a movie about
your life like you should that's what
you should do you should write a movie
be all the best stories completely
totally factual completely totally
accurate insane that would be a fucking
chaotic movie yeah 15 year old girl 15
year old girl you're at it shot off
while she's holding her baby and dealing
drugs and this guy's running around
naked he's got a rabbit up his ass
diabetes medicine oh that's nothing let
me tell you more story
so when I I was about probably but like
I said I was about ten I left it's not a
really nice figure so I learned you had
a nice figure I was fucking third grade
honestly Tina are you sure yes Jim I
know so how do you know I remember
everybody used to say I was fine and I
didn't know what fine was Wow when I
turn I tell you this story so I'm buddy
1011 so sometime I could just walk away
from home nobody gave a fuck so I go
downtown to the local Hilton Hotel
because I said I want to go see what
white people doing you know rich white
people cuz I thought everybody stayed at
the Hilton was rich you know and plus I
went in there because we'd have no
fucking a/c so I was standing in front
of the door when it does open the a/c
hit me my fucking face so I'm standing
at the phone booth one day in this white
man say hey you wanna come go to my room
me I'm like huh and he thought like like
he's jacking his dick and I was like
okay honestly I go to his room jump and
he had me jack his dick and I jacked his
white man dick and he paid me $100 I'm
like are you gonna fucking be here
tomorrow so I'm thinking this is my
first job I go home and tell my mom I
got a job downtown jack and white being
dicks for $100 you told her that yes you
wanted to go to ghetto for Jack and dick
you might get some oatmeal cookies you
go get our damn bunch of dollars oh my
god oh my god oh my god you at the time
11:11 you told your mother you got a job
jacking off white men's dicks for $100
and she wants to go with you yeah that
might be the craziest fuckin story I
said they're not hiring to fuckin oh
yeah forty that she wasn't really cute
it's funny do you have to qualify that
the 14th but she was cute as well she
wasn't cute at all you know but you mean
once you only have four teeth it's like
what is really cute your tongue
something about being toothless is not
that appealing to us
wow that is so crazy your mom wanted to
go with you yeah when I was look
was where we saw all this go what cities
Atlanta it without it really started in
a Buble this is when I knew she was
fucked or like on Friday
my grandfather customers was fall asleep
and why they were sleep
my mama would make me rob them and for
every person that I robbed I got five
dollars per person and I probably was
seven or eight I remember that shit like
yesterday and I told I said you taking
advantage of me I should be making more
money it's all cool extra for Tiffany's
thing because I've been watching Sesame
Street but neither one of us knew what
the fuck to for 10 percent of the
robberies have you watching Sesame
Street yeah oh you didn't know what it
was I was like it's $10 so she gave me
$10 for every wallet that I stole and I
fucking would get up on Saturday morning
and play pac-man to the fucking Sun go
down I only did it because I wanted to
play pac-man it's incredible yeah what a
crazy inviting us and then getting past
that and looking back on it like when
you were say asking does but this really
happen or am I crazy like how does that
feel now when you tell these stories you
you be in this normal person now you
know as normal as you can be having
children that are doing great living in
the suburbs staying calm like this this
has got to feel like another life right
it is another life yeah I used to hurt
me like it used to like I would cry when
this shit come up and I was like I'm not
you know I have I have this whole thing
in life and shit gonna get me down and I
learned that from a fourth grade teacher
because you know I used to go to school
I'll just stinking kid I was a poor kid
but I had a teacher named is true that
would tell me Patricia get here earlier
and I will bring you clean clothes and I
will comb your hair so we were in the
bathroom one day and she just was
combing my hair and she said I want you
to remember that you can be anything in
the world you wanna be all you got to do
is believe and I later just died this
year and I when I did time in prison any
time I got it low
anytime I wanted to question something
that I was trying to do in life I went
back to miss truth cuz she to me she was
the first person to ever believe in me
and I'm 42 years old and I still fucking
quote me is true that's crazy
isn't it amazing I'm one person like
that can have an impact to think of
those two people's impacts the one lady
who told you you were funny and then
that lady the caseworkers my gun momma
now so every day yeah she must be blown
away by see when I got more in dealt
with the stores like you know after I
tell you all the story they probably
take a month you know people call me can
you tell me this story one more time and
a lot of time never my meal shit how
many do you write these down do write
them down you just confident you gonna
remember them all I do remember my mouth
well it's like the six that you working
on like now I talks about my mom and my
egg and I talked about being married so
I really don't need to
Uncle Jack and II you know right now I
tell that story later on in life on
stage I talk about being a drug-dealing
them you know just to basic just
stretching the surface right you know
cuz I'm not a star so it's only so much
you can put out there before you make
you fuckin audience cry uh-huh
so you know when you when you become
Chris Rock they'll take anything from
you but I'm gonna miss Pat fucking
nobody I gotta give it to him easy and
you gotta remember I'm a fuckin black
woman talking to a white audience most
of my fans are white water I have no
fucking idea I appreciate y'all to the
fullness hey I love the fucking I don't
give a fuck if you had one I thank you
for supporting me what do you think it
is about the audience being all white
like how'd that happen I don't know
honestly I don't I did a radio show
called Bob and Tom in Indianapolis
that's why I got a lot of them from and
they just started coming I mean I will
go into that mainstream club you know
mostly white people and I would tell
these stories and people be like wow and
I still help people be like want to cry
I was like get the fuck away from me I'm
not fuckin crying over this shit I'm
over it
wow so it's just because they
don't have anything like that in their
life and you think people like to know
that you overcame mmm you know I could
be on crack like my sister my sister
been smoking crack from day one she been
on drugs all her life and I think that's
how she dealt with her pain a fucking
molestation and all that bullshit that
we went through his kids she'll never
admit it because she haven't faced up to
the problem yet but with me I just
packed the shit in the back of my head
so I think I think when I tell my
stories people at home going through
whatever they're going through and it
was like fuck I thought my problem was
big hell no this bitch had to pull a
crippled uncle's leg back in here come
stick his dick in at 8:00 so you realize
your life ain't as bad as you I think
after you hear my story like fuck I had
good pants it's the feel-good story here
I can't even imagine so you start 11
years ago you start telling this on
stage and when when you first start
doing it what you doing it you do an
open mic nights and when I started
talking about my life about six years
ago when I moved to Indianapolis so six
years ago yeah so the five years before
that you were doing all black clubs yeah
all Atlanta mm-hm
and so then you were you were more like
everyone else around you just trying to
like do whatever everybody else did try
to get laughs yeah so moving to
Indianapolis is that when you started
getting paid work or you getting paid
work before that um I started getting
paid working in Annapolis I became I
became a comedian I was bullshitting the
whole first time and my husband used to
always say nobody want to hear that
chicken shit on stage and I didn't know
what he was talking about he's like it's
not funny I mean he wouldn't say it to
hurt my feelings but he said he wouldn't
he wouldn't support it he never would
come see me he's like that ain't funny
you know anybody could talk why are you
gonna talk about your bedroom on stage
and I said oh you just fucking hate but
when I became Miss Pat who I am today
with my life he's more supportive like
when I say I'm gonna do Joe Rogan Park
case he was like here's my credit card
but be folks like I'm not giving you no
money that I'll tell on fucking roast
jokes so it makes a difference like he
only seen me once but yes once I can't
Williams when I open for Katt Williams
here
fighting them out that's the only time
he's ever seen you because you know what
he said I was never funny to him
I was always serious he said people just
laughed at what I said they thought what
I was trying to be funny but I was just
being me Wow so for him it wasn't funny
no because you know what when I did Bob
and Tom and I talked about being my baby
daddy shot me a hit another do shot me
in a titty his his co-workers listeners
you shot your wife to do he's like that
was a fucking abuse questions about me
he would escape my dude that was not
fucking me that was a do before me oh I
was so broken before I met this dude is
your nipple like together still or is it
just like gone no no is there it's a
little damaged but it's there the other
piece in its store right you said you're
saying no what I was saying when I do my
mammogram and they smashed my boob you
can see the the gun D what does it call
the gun the fragment
oh my mallet fragments yes Wow no spots
and they look like breasts council but
they know it's not breasts council so
they have on my chart and my mammogram
off is been shot in the right t they're
missing nipple they say titty on your
mammogram well whatever booth yeah if
you start calling the titty you might
want to where's your fucking certificate
most cool they always titties Joe always
yeah that's a good name for him I got no
problem with that what do you call them
titties are great okay I have a friend
who says my friend steve says titties
for things that are good he's like we're
going on a titties camping trip I say
tits like that's tits or the tits yeah
boobs I don't have boobs I got TD mushy
dang he's like balls and I have to put
grease up on them so they slide across
my stomach easily so they don't fucking
create friction and make a sword
really I got real shit job we were
talking about your husband before the
podcast started about he became a vegan
well yes ton of weight lost some pounds
that's crazy
yeah he says health was going down I
mean knees and shit hurt and everything
and he just said I'm not eating this
shit anymore
well if you're a hundred pounds
overweight just imagine that guy
he might be God carrying uh extra
hundred pounds like just everywhere you
go you have to put 100 pounds of your
shoulders like everything will start
breaking after a while that's what most
people are doing that are hundred pounds
overweight they just don't think about
it right yeah so he got a shit together
became a vegan and eaten meat in two
years wow that's crazy and did you would
you stick food in his face like smell
this bitch don't bother my husband is so
fucking strong-minded this motherfucker
going on a 40-day water just / water I
was like oh you like looking crazy we
can't live on just water
he drops so much weight just on water
and went to work every day
that's crazy you're not supposed to do
that that's what I told I think this
stupid fucker on phone face on YouTube
that told me can live off water I was
like look at your fucking titties
they're fucking just go you need to eat
something
40 days 40 days of noe to drink juice
nothing he didn't even brush his fucking
teeth he breasts away water supplement
or some kind of no you did water well
let's see how many days do you think it
says online
I'm not saying his story's not true but
if you can call me you know I believe
him but I'm saying how many days I did
do you think it says online that you
could only drink water before you died I
did a 10 day water lemon fast where I
couldn't no we didn't do no lemon he
didn't how many days I would say you
could live to be thirty days with just
water and maybe some stuff but I think
it's 21 you be dead like the last two
weeks I think that's like this isn't
that the the story behind drunken and
afraid are they and not drunken and
afraid naked and afraid don't they don't
they say that like it's 21 days is the
day okay let's find out can you live off
only water
go to Yahoo Answers it says the average
person kid depending upon your body fat
the average person go from a week to one
month or so without food so this guy
went 40 days he like probably hit the
boundaries he was so she was shaking so
bad and I was like can you please
fucking me how you just gonna down me I
don't even know what a policy it is so
crazy you had to do some kind of
supplement okay there's a hunger strike
Wikipedia page apparently you could live
as many as 74 days that's the longest a
person's ever gone with just having
water oh my god
hunger strikers dying after 52 to 74
days so 74 is a big one that's
ridiculous
yeah Gandhi Gandhi apparently went
through a bunch of hunger strikes when
he was a I didn't know Gandhi was all
alive so young uh-oh so long ago it was
1922 only way I can go on a hunger
strike if they shut down all the
chick-fil-a do you mad on Sunday why
does chick-fil-a have to be so religious
they can't do well by that time I don't
fucking soak all of that crap into my
body so much I love chick-fil-a so much
I made my son get his first job there so
we can get a discount it was um there's
there's certain people that are that are
famous hunger strikers apparently a guy
who fasted to death his name is boy
tribe pronouncing this J atin das das
Jatin das maybe it was a hundred and
sixteenth day of his fast they gave up
their hunger strike surpassing the 97
day world record for hunger strikes
which was led by an Irish revolutionary
so apparently you can fuckin do that you
can not eat for 40 days like your
husband did he's crazy though like he
was probably on death's door I know he
was so fuckin wee and he went to work
and worked at my husband build the
transmission for Allison Transmission
that's a crazy way to decide to lose
weight I mean he just wanted to cleanse
his body
yourself but you know his skin turns so
pretty I thought that his kids skin
changed yeah it became super smoothing
how many days in to his family cuz I you
know I travel I try to travel at the
time I was traveling a lot so you know I
come home and I was like goddamn you
losing a lot of weight dude they're not
fighting on the fucking water I was like
you need to fucking eat yeah but did he
ever get to a point where you were
worried about him falling asleep no not
really falling asleep driving I was
worried about him fucking he was always
cold
so I was like you call you back to die
what the fuck you gonna leave me here
with each other I gotta do gate oh wow
so then when after forty days he starts
eating he starts eating and what did he
eat he he started to like fruit he went
into fruit first
just real gentle yeah that's gotta be a
big shock to your system yeah that's
what he said he don't want to shock his
system he doesn't shit all the time he
don't go that long anymore you might go
20 days 15 days oh really
mm-hm I've heard of people doing like
six days of juice that's told me to call
him and ask no i blissing I'm not
questioning I'm saying I don't know
anybody's ever done that that's a very
extreme dude he just liked that when he
said when he just I tell you he used to
smoke cigarettes and nobody knows this
and he just stopped and he started back
one time when I got arrested he went to
court with me when I was getting my life
together and I needed my driver's
license and they just said you have five
thousand dollars or for traffic tikis
how you want to paint it and so my
husband I can only get five hundred
dollars out and one you know during the
day that's it
he said well you gotta go get some money
we're gonna lock her ass up he started
by smoking because he never been to jail
Wow
that's the hardest one probably quitting
smoking no he would call Turkey he and
after I got out of jail
he stopped he didn't gain by the week he
always do every fucking thing Kotick Joe
I've been trying to lose weight forever
I've tried all the nice shit out there
Nutrisystem did work but I can't afford
this shit so now I'm back at my ex like
guy
that's really cheap xline yeah what's a
X I start taking shit chamoy he gets mad
at me cuz I do x-ray and I get mad at
him cuz he do water yeah I think X lakhs
is probably worse for you than water I
know I do the math on the mild form but
I mean all that's do your is a diuretic
right I mean what does it do it makes me
shit yeah of pounds like if I can eat a
cheeseburger and I really want to get
rid of this cheeseburgers right through
you it's a PO based diet okay is a way
to do it
I know Joe I can't resist I like coffee
and I really can't drink coffee because
I got sensitive nipples coffee make my
nipples really sore almost but I'm
serious option makes your nipples
caffeine fucks my breasts up I got
caffeine breasts I'm called caffeine
breast and women's out there who's
listening they know I'm telling the
truth is a common term yes when you
drink too much caffeine it fucks with
your titties so I just went and had a
mammogram I'm just my left titty two
weeks ago Wow because I had too much
caffeine so when I lay out the caffeine
my breasts stop being so but I like
chick-fil-a coffee fibrocystic breast
that's what it's called see that's
that's the medical term yeah fibrocystic
gifts yeah you google everything
constantly curious yeah pain or
discomfort in both breasts pain comes
and goes with the period but can last
through the entire month breasts feel
full swollen yeah heavy yeah and
caffeine does that to my breasts well my
nipples are hard to set in a brothel
replimat
at the rapid and tissue paper wow that's
crazy
but coffee fucks me up but I love it
some women get it from eating chocolate
yeah I'm caffeine or eating high fat
foods that causes their symptoms but
according to this medical page there's
no clear proof of what's causing it your
arms pains will not come off for
caffeine my titties stop being so
honestly I know my teeny
well it makes sense fibrocystic breasts
juice and that's what is called pain
for lumpy breasts yes lumpy and it
almost make you feel like you got you
know like you feel alone so I went in
two weeks ago and I was like I'm very
paranoid cause breast cancer running my
family so I know my daddy size so I was
like just check my damn titty so my
doctor my doctor I really I fuckin love
my doctor like when he giving me a
gynecology I'm like how did this
BlueCross BlueShield pussy look doctor
so they gave me a mammogram on one
braces like you don't have any fucking
lumps lay out the damn coffee oh that's
all it is that's that's fascinating
that's amazing that does that dyrdek
they have fibrocystic dick cells we do
Roman and you turn about 40 your body's
like a 64 Chevy you must repair that
bitch like honestly since we friends me
I tell you okay so when I turned 40
my psychic came on one day wouldn't go
off so I had to go in there and they go
I don't know the medical term but I know
you're gonna I know you gonna google it
they have to burn inside of your vagina
oh good lord
and they burnt my vagina Joe and it will
beatbox it for like three weeks
it was a it didn't hurt it was a boot
boot so I called my doctor I was like my
pussy is singing can you stop my pussy
face I was like oh no it was healing it
was healing yes so in the healing it was
poppin and it was sounded like it was
making music
what kind of healing was going on there
no but it was like boo boo I could
almost feel it in my stomach and my
daughter Norma comedian and I was I'm
serious daughter my pussy's beatboxing
so I go up there he said it was healing
so essentially they had a cauterize is
that the term yeah something like that
so you were bleeding so much that they
had to go in there they neither do two
thing they either burn the inside of you
or they give you hit directly and I
don't want history so there was no other
way to stop the bleeding no good I just
break down crazy feeling they burnt the
inside of you to cool everything off
that's cool oh you stopped the flow yeah
no that's crazy
yeah god this extra things that women
have to worry about breast cancer
one like they say dudes get breast
cancer but you know oh y'all gotta worry
about his drop penises that's it and
they made ya soft wieners mmm yeah but
they fix that they have pills yeah but
they don't have anything for broken
titties and broken vagina you know dry
assholes
I know people people get jhanas
tightened up I've heard that's
unbelievably painful oh really yeah they
go in there and fucking you know woman's
have a few kids and their vaginas all
blown out it doesn't blow it out I still
got some grip you gotta use I'm sorry
depends on a woman this I know what
you're saying but there's realities
about the shape of the body like about
like stretch marks a lot of that's
genetic some people get stretch marks
some people do not so be honest they
don't have any did she know probably
just crazy genes
some people they stretch way the fuck
out and have a kid in all goes right
back into place it's amazing and then
some people one kid and they're
Dunnsville the whole thing the whole
package is just done like someone just
drove a truck through water my daughter
was like that I was like don't have a
baby because his baby's gonna fuck up
your figure
I say you young girls need to stop
fucking trying to be Mama's take your
body and abuse them have fun have a baby
when you fucking in your late 30s before
about the drought don't give a man an
opportune to fuck up your flat stomach
what if she wants a baby more than she
had a baby now she fed she fucking out
of shape and she still try to wear that
sexy shit and I'm like oh no boo-boo
take them home short south it's not
gonna work you miss your opportunity let
my fucking son get you pregnant
oh no boo-boo take you take that whole
shit off I told you nothing that my son
get you pregnant holy shit that's for me
there was a thing in the news the other
day where ages 18 to 24 are twice as
likely to get vaginal surgery than most
women I guess it's really popular with
the young kids now to get the Barbie cut
where they chopped off all the lips and
everything so it's just the line you
know like
lipless pussy it's it's the porn that
people are trying to get the morning
look you know like the perfect that must
be exactly what these kids are crazy no
everybody wanted daily lives what is
vagina lips called la ba la vela labia
lady everybody maybe you only read it
and never say icon it yeah what's gonna
kiss the stuff that's coming out of it I
mean the panning line is down to catch
at the Falls but it's gotta like run
down the sides meet curtains
mm-hmm meet Curtis yeah I don't know I
think it is pornography though because
you think about like pornography is so
it's so bright and visual you know like
if you got a camera you if you're having
sex with someone you know there's a lot
of stuff going on right there's a their
faces in your face you're kissing you're
touching each other but if you're
watching a porn a lot of times they're
just showing you like the insertion
they're showing you the dick in the
vagina they're showing you the body
parts are showing you things moving and
you're concentrating on like this one
particular area and you can decide for
whatever reason like that that is that's
what you got to focus on like that need
to trim up your fucking yard you could
clean your hedges so it looks like these
videos well you know what jump I got
stomachs sitting on my vagina ain't seen
a 90 so maybe I don't know what's gonna
go down maybe I need some what is it
called Batman pussy - good God Almighty
yeah I don't think you need it no I
don't need a job I mean don't nobody
needs that don't do that and plus some
guys like it like Jim Norton he's always
talking about he loves big pussy lips it
drives him crazy that let me get that
fixed there's some famous porn star I
think her name was Houston she did
something with her vagina lips like she
sold them or something like that sell
you'll agree that yeah there was
something crazy I'm trying to remember
the story she I think she got surgery
then she did something with it
she was also one of the first people to
ever do a gangbang remember still like
the future she was and we saw that she
didn't hit all the time we first came
out Joe come on I mean in a porn
oh oh okay GIMP a
one of those giant ones like 500 people
like yeah she's like 500 people have
seat this is the thing they say it's 500
people but it's really like 60 people
and they fuck her a bunch of times they
like go through the line and they keep
going and you know they act like a new
guy I think some of them have actually
gone big of her today
I'm not into porn I'm not into porn no
it was Houston she saw her labia for
$50,000 and we just come by to do balm
and suck on for skin yeah like like a
silky blanket
what deal how long will it last $50,000
how long is it good for sit in this
freezer somewhere he's probably had it
dried out just like eating his like beef
jerky beef jerky of a job I need to call
my daughter that she might like that is
there a photo of said labia no I don't
want to see no sub labias I just I just
don't understand after picture of a
pussy if there's not that's right and
it's just reportedly like it's okay so
it could be yeah I'm more for the
woman's of trying to keep down you know
yeah I'm just one of Aegina jacket just
I don't understand it's gotta be that
it's got to be the porn it's gotta be
he's gotta be I mean think about fake
breasts fake breasts or so-called you
know what the other thing I was at I did
k-rock the other day and they brought up
Korean women who win the like Miss Korea
you know Miss Korea they look exactly
the same like pull up pull up there's a
video anyway no no this is way crazy cuz
it's all about plastic surgery they get
a very specific type of look by plastic
surgery it's super super super common
amongst clothes we all love them but
that's what's crazy it doesn't make any
sense
because they look exactly the same so
over the years like so how think of how
many look at this plastic surgery blamed
for making all Miss Korea contestants
look alike look at what these women look
like they look exactly the same like you
could have photos of any one of them
doing something and then tell the police
and they'll go to charge for the crime I
mean look at what they look like I mean
I don't like generalizations you say Oh
everybody looks the same well maybe to
you you race
fuck no those girls look exactly the
same and what they're doing is
apparently they're going and getting a
very specific type of surgery and they
shape their face to a very specific way
and they do it with their chin and they
do it with their eyes and they do it
with their noses and when it's all said
at least very close really close when
it's all said and done there no no no no
there's a lot of before and afters this
is a real common problem in oh I would
say common I wouldn't say a problem
rather it's a cultural issue in Korea
the plastic surgery has run rampant
because if you don't want to have sex
with your wife you send one of them over
there and when was I mean oh so if you
won't want to have sex with your husband
exactly just like that just seen your
husband jumping you go why did you go
out with your boyfriend sit in there and
he realizes that extra work done down
there
no don't no this is not my wife unless
he thinks that she had something done
but it's just uh it's very strange that
they're all adopting this uniform look
that's scary to me
you know that's the scary uh there's
before and after of one you could see
look at this you know she looks very
actually they should do that joke I like
the karate key if you could tell the big
the big thing that they're getting is
the you know what that what's been
quoted is the anime I if you look at the
eyes they're very big and but you know
there's kind of stretch I don't stress
the eyes out
they cut the lids they changed the lids
they changed this shape of the lid they
they go in there and they it's just too
much pie slice out pull that bitch
together in their eyes like this that's
what they do to people when they get
older - I know what do - did that has
eyes done
like to get your eyes done also and you
like this it's nothing like seeing a
dude looking like an old last woman with
plastic surgery Kenny Rogers have you
seen him lately
it is the creepiest thing ever he's like
on a commercial right now anything Kenny
Rogers terrifying you know Kenny Rogers
is I don't know yeah
yeah we'll do you ever see what he looks
like now no yeah let me see would
recognize him
really yeah poor guy he's pretty open
about it I think he's had conversations
about her talked about I fucked up shit
I mean you kind of have to talk about
how you fucked up when you look like
this because it's it's so obvious
well Joan Rivers had a lot of it yeah
that's not a bad picture dude in that
picture he kind of looks normal but
there's yeah that's a bad picture that's
a bad picture could get get a good one
because there's some good ones that are
like really shocking just pull up Kenny
Rogers bad plastic surgery and you'll
get some good ones I was on the beach
the other day and this dude caught a
manta ray you know what a manta ray is
and he pulls it in from the water and
there's it's in Malibu and there's all
these rich people that have houses there
and they think think it's hell people
what to do for whatever reason so the
dude had already released the manta he
caught it and released it you know they
were trying to catch fish and they just
caught this manta ray accidentally and
so he he's releasing it and this lady
comes running cuz this other lady was
like you know they're doing this they're
torturing that animal they pulled it out
of the ocean and this chick comes
running to tell them what to do and when
I tell you that she looked like a
monster like I am not exactly I mean
this poor lady
I felt bad like she had done so much to
herself it was like her face had been so
pulled back and the guys are listening
our podcast fans the guys who caught the
fish so they're probably listening to it
right now they they were talking to me
before so I assumed if you know who you
are what's up nice guys you know regular
looking young tattooed up dudes who are
out there fishing they caught this
big-ass manta ray but this lady came
running and when I saw her as she
approached them I had a visual I mean a
like a vision visible like I felt and
tangible like quiver like I saw her I
made the visual contact like my eyes hit
her face like I just fucked up here did
you do and not only that she's in this
crazy ass fucking multi-million dollar
beach house you know this be those
beaches in Malibu or ridiculous and he's
also we're cheating with somebody who
eyes is not wide open why he sleep he's
probably just xanax the fuck out just
trying to deal with her and him and
own life he's a probably a mess - I
don't know who he was or who she was but
it was the arrogance of this crazy lady
running up these guys she was guys throw
it back throw it back thank you you
could keep a manta ray and eat it if you
wanted to nobody could stop you and it's
like you beat look out there that's the
ocean like that's a really fucking big
it's the idea that you know this guy on
the side of these gonna do anything to
the population of the manta rays like
that's not how animals die they die
because of giant nets that they pull
amongst these huge boats and they they
pulled them out of that's what's over
pop overfishing it's not a dude on the
rocks pulling something but in her idea
was a you know in her mind she was gonna
tell this do it demand for yeah but I
felt so bad memories are cute they're
kind of different they're a unique
species i oh yeah they're kind of cool
but you know you ever had skate like at
a restaurant it's delicious what is
skate skate is a manta ray it's a type
of Ray that thing name it wasn't that
one that was not the one that he caught
he got he was like a stingray it had
like one I don't know what kind of Ray
it was it was cool-looking but he read
he let it go immediately he'd already
let it go when this lady came running
over but she just had such a monster
face monster faces so I'm going to take
this manta ray and beat the hell out of
you if you don't get this beat your face
up they called police so fast they
probably have I don't know how they do
it but you know like this came Rodgers
that's a good bad picture of them why
you say it's bad the one that eyes eyes
and his nose looks like he's high as
fuck he might be in California that's
not a good one though there's some other
ones here it just looks really awful
well there's other I've seen a one
comparison make this one's a good one to
it maybe yeah that's it that's it holy
fuck you look great
I can't not be no Kenny Rogers this is
daddy no it's him they changed the shape
of his face and it doesn't make you look
better either it just makes you look
different and not a good different his
eye was wide open
you can't shoot that shit in your face
either man that thing that everyone's
doing with her put filler in their face
not just boat but the black girls are
putting it in the ass they put a a so
many train
Ginger's have died I'm serious a little
stuff and things there no there was no
you haven't heard about it googly they
was taking people was telling names
giving them but shots but it was putting
fucking corn oil Hawking oil and it is
me and I know I know so many black girls
with fake booties
that's a photo with some captions on a
field yeah when I shit hard enough ain't
nothing make a new one a crowd they
can't go in and cut it out no I don't
know I don't I wouldn't let nobody shoot
no no fucking Home Depot stuff in my
booty well some women that had their
lips done back in the day are there they
were scarred for life there was this
poor lady that used to live down the
street for me and she had like she
talked to you and she had a line like
right here from here to here a straight
line inside her lips from where she had
these artificial lips put in and so when
you she would talk to you you would see
the scar like the scar on her upper lip
was so distracting I was like what did
you do just see probably Gannicus takes
your place wanted lips like yours which
one natural ones
couldn't get it I always get compliments
on my lips yeah beautiful lips
thank you wait a minute
what jealous that I have beautifully
beautiful white women want they want
those plump juicy lips you know white
women sometimes they'll go drastic
measures and they won't big asses now
mm-hmm
yeah they're getting them too yeah yeah
was a botched botched towards more
plastics today I was watching one last
night where the woman got the the fake
bud and it started to it popped or
something like that started going into
her leg and her enter and stuff and they
couldn't get it out because it started
growing with the muscles I start
attaching the muscles so they couldn't
take it out and so she just decided to
get another one put in there and then
that one didn't take because there was
just a whole kid
button plants and then then she could
just flip them like she would sit down
and would flip upside down and stuff
like that lady I thought I don't yeah
Facebook I saw that lady she just flip
her ass inside out and it was a bad job
and I was like as long as the long as
the ass is sticking the right way is not
a bad
it was like a little fly I'll lower your
standards ya know it's a bad job if you
can flip it around who are you a
spokesperson for the surgeon I don't
know I maybe when it was turned the
right way to ass was nice and curvy when
it flipped over like a plate that was
upside down and I asked could you
imagine what it feels like if you
grabbed that thing like you're wrestling
with something like your fish is
underneath the surface I mean it can't
be no different in sucking fate teeth I
got a cross buy at a strip club in
Dayton Ohio and it felt just like boobs
on your butt but it hurts but she got
the really big ones the ones that were
like the size of basketballs and so it
was just like gel she was right
very jelly uh yeah she probably went too
far yeah that's what happens everybody
goes too far it's like some women can
get breast jobs and they just get a
little little bit of an enlargement and
it looks great yeah and then other women
get crazy and they get those basketballs
put in and you're like they may have
back problems and they look stupid and
they may look cleavage sag I'm just
gonna keep it what I got I'm gonna keep
the same man Joe I don't have time to be
putting cutting off my lever use
knowledge on your skin lips whatever you
want to call it because that stuff gonna
dry your vagina you're never gonna have
wet vagina without having those lips
you dumb half is that how it works or
the lips like help what helps keeps the
moisture is in there moisture in there
Monica keep the shit wait I'm learning a
lot yes I can't do it I don't want to
pull my neck back my eyes back I mean
you know you're gonna get old shit is
gonna stop working that's why God gave
you hand when my husband ain't working
I'm on I just unstick his balls and we
keep it moving we watch the news and go
to bed you know what I think I think
that also when people are doing their
early adopters you know I'm saying like
the people that got the original boob
jobs like those they leaked and there's
silicone and you know the poor people
got sick and remember how many people
got like lupus and all these diseases
from tit I knew a girl got lupus from
her breast job she had a leaky breast
job and she got lupus like she was all
fucked up her immune system was jacked
but now like they have it down where
like you know it's very few reactions
it's a different feel to it like you
were talking about it's like a gummy
bear boots yeah they feel like a real
breast they feel like like really firm
real breasts and I think that in the
future and not so far away either
they're gonna be able to give you
injections that make a woman's breasts
grow like they're gonna be able to grow
naturally every bracelet you know I
think if you if you don't have breasts
that shit is probably ready Terry go
back down the line you got a bunch of
flat breasted us and shit you're
supposed to have to you are going I want
it breast and my coke Mike the I
remember the look girls my name is like
if you rub butter on your titties they
would grow in your ass they would grow
so we went in the frigerator took all my
momma butter and we just soaked our
chests in butter and so and I think
that's why I got titties a day so ladies
it don't spin your money at the plastic
surgeon just buy some fucking I can't
believe it not butter put the two boobs
in there and soak them overnight and see
if they grow in two weeks I'm not sure
if that works I don't know either but
look at me I'm rocking a 44 double D
grease up on the reason there's
apparently there's a lot of people been
working at this they've been trying to
do this for a long time in this there's
a bunch of ways that can kind of help a
little bit but then not exactly
they're not really ready to grow tits
yet but you know what someone brought up
the other day that made a lot of sense
they were saying they're like when a
woman man becomes a woman when he
becomes transgender becomes a woman they
start taking estrogen shots and a lot of
times they grow never depressed they do
I got a son who eats too much Mac
doughnuts he got nice size 8 cups just
on the same note overweight is
overweight
so they should gain weight and grow tits
no it might not work it might work but
it might not work what they're saying is
that they can give a man injections yeah
he starts growing like natural boobs
wouldn't they be able to give a woman
estrogen and would that make the promise
fuckers up because we already produce
[Laughter]
you come home cooking the cat yeah right
yeah you don't want to do that there's a
lot of fucking problems apparently with
silicone and press
implants but particularly the silicone
gel can cause connective tissue or
autoimmune diseases such as rheumatoid
arthritis and lupus neurological
disorders cancer even new silicone
related diseases that didn't exist
before breast enhancement surgery so you
got nice tits but can't open your hands
you could have some serious but this
girl was all fucked up that had lupus
she was a mess you know like that's a
those autoimmune diseases like that like
lupus or no joke you know is there any
plastic surgery that you would get you
know what I think man I think we're so
close to them being able to figure out
how to do stuff without it like I don't
need plastic surgery I'm beautiful
perfect as I am but I've had it I had
hair transplants when I was younger
obviously what happened such as my hair
was falling out and I was trying to
fight against this no you a shave it
should have shaved it maybe shaving your
trash that's one way to look at it yeah
white people stopped getting hair
transplant all you gotta do is go to the
hood and get something called a quick
weave yes it's a haul what you watching
on my here it's a whole head of hair for
$50 listen that's not gonna work with me
I do Jiu Jitsu you know we don't get
they don't get it like this anymore
white dudes are not allowed to get
weaves it's just too pathetic it's what
I go around with the toupee that be
shaking in shit and we can take this
shake it that off yeah they don't need
those shave that I know a guy who works
at the Lowe's in my area he got one in
this fucking horrible it makes him look
like a child molester
I mean like look like you killed babies
but you take the hug last week I know
but I don't like he creeps me out
because you know it's nothing like
seeing somebody with a bad weave when
you wear we right so you have a good one
and him having a bad one is offensive to
you yeah like when John Travolta wears
this beautiful one and he goes in the
Academy Awards are you like that's a
respectable leave yes I mean it's gotta
look good the problem is it's glued to
your head not anymore this is sold in
Sonia Sonia Sonia Sonia
the dudes bald like if he was bald like
I have stubble up here but it was all
just it was going it was gone the party
was over that what happens is they take
hair from the back your head and yeah
it's never gonna fall out and they move
it to the joke was that it's like taking
a bunch of really healthy people and you
move into a neighborhood where
everybody's dying because that's what
it's like no they stayed they stuck
around they're the new residents that
you like they Ronnie yeah yeah they grow
but the old hair that used to be there
along with the transplants that's that
shit all falls out eventually so when
you grow hair what do it look like what
do you look like
no no I mean I have enough hair to grow
my hair out not look like I have cancer
but it's not it's pretty close it was
going it was getting thinner it was a
cotton candy year it was getting honey
it was more and more and it was annoying
is that shave it yeah they do well they
do it now they do want what they call
single follicle so they take like one
hair at a time they'll take it from
there and put it up there but the bottom
line is you only have so much hair back
here and especially if you go full
Ronald McDonald like if your hair goes
bald like way back to the edge imagine
taking that little edge and trying to
populate your entire head good luck you
don't have enough hair so then they
figured out how to clone hair and that's
what they're working on now they're
working on cloning hair but at the same
time they're also working on some other
shit like that'll just genetically
they'll be able to inject it in your
skin and it'll grow hair like crazy
they're pretty close to be able to
figure that out because it's some sort
of a giant multi multi-billion dollar
industry dudes losing their hair but if
I could give anybody any advice from
someone who's already shaved her head
shave your fucking he was trying to hold
on so like freeing and I don't truly do
not give a fuck like it doesn't bother
me at all anymore my hair used to fuck
with me when I was falling out because I
was thinking about shaving it but I
wasn't sure if I could you know I need
you to just just jump in and do it but
once I did it was like oh god yeah once
I did it that was like oh this is so
much better my husband used to have that
kid and play fate you can't that oh my
god can you fucking get this goddamn
Tico
hole on the top of your head let it go
and look like a bottle top opener what
did you want him to do with it
cut the shit off he was losing his hair
was thinning and it was like it would
grow around the fade but it had a hole
in the top so he was good until winner
what the fuck you know like he was
keeping a little safe on top his head
yeah we talked about that poor Jason
Alexander decided at like 50 something
years old to wear our to pay out of
nowhere
you don't know Seinfeld the show
Seinfeld George from Seinfeld Seinfeld
no you know he turned me on to sign for
you so they don't want to watch this
boring that show then I watched us like
just a fucking great show it's a fucking
great show yeah we spent many nights
watching Safi you know do you know a
Richard Pryor story yes I do you know
his story like growing up in a brothel
you know yeah and your story's like five
times more crazy than Richard Pryor
really yeah yeah I think so it's pretty
close I mean Richard Pryor suck no I
didn't turn gay for two weeks I reach a
book
he turned gay only probably more than
two weeks probably more than two weeks I
don't know I mean there's a different
time to if you stop and think about like
what was going on in the 70s think about
all the people that have a shit well the
brothel right yeah brother grew up it's
prostitute house but you you know you
look at like allegedly David Bowie and
Mick Jagger went gay for a while you
know like um what's name from The Who
what the fuck's his name not Roger
Daltrey the other guy Jamie Townsend
Pete Townsend Pete Townsend was gay for
a while like even do you think is shit
when you in Hollywood there's no more
you don't hang out of a Johnny you don't
turn it inside out you don't stuck your
foot in it kicked across the room you
don't bake the pussy you're on the beach
you're done banging and pussy you don't
you don't set it on fire so you're like
well you know what I'm gonna go over and
play with this dick and see if I can say
thanks to dick not that it gay they're
just trying to do something else I think
that's what they do I hearing just in
Hollywood
cuz in the Midwest they just keep the
same old bitch with the beard who smoke
cigarettes and coke babies on the hills
maybe you got a good point yeah I think
this for a lot of dudes it probably is
that they probably want to just expand
their experiences yeah it's like getting
fingers put in ass I tell you let me
think
so I went I did I had to do a hosting
for a dildo party I'm not into dildos I
don't want to fight you get it how did
you get this job they thought I was
funny they came to show so they like
come host our dildo party they have a
dildo party yes and women loves this
business they got up traders hey they
got big statement you know do you know
that they got the news that the date
with the suctions on it so you stick it
to the toilet and you just have sex with
yourself when you finish your inches you
rinse it off and put it in the
dishwasher whatever funky do it right so
I host this dildo party so they give me
this little thing and I said well what
is this she said go home and spice up
your relationship so I was like oh my
fuck relationship could use some spices
how are you been married for 23 so I was
like what would I do this she's like
this is bowel dose she said you take
this fella you dust his balls and you
ball dust but it came with a pink fella
so I go home with this bodice and I was
like open your leg I got some bowel dust
and I pull out this Feltham I was like
if you don't get that gay ass get away
from my balls participate what if it was
black he wouldn't it was a fucking fella
it was that families who do what a fuck
that you can't bow does you're not
putting this is cuz it was pink it would
turn him off no I think it was bowed
down spearing my husband I gonna do out
an extra shit why is pink universally a
girl's color I love pink well it's
nothing wrong with the color but I mean
like yeah this lighter is a pink lighter
it's a Hello Kitty lighter so it's
definitely lighter that's my lighter
exactly so a girl just being silly but
this is pink like why is that color like
a girl color why is white it's because
we rehearsal because when you grew up
your mom put you girls in a pink bedroom
and bought pink stuff and when you're I
was boys were blue colors like there's a
terminus sake so when you walk around
with an ugly-ass baby that was a girl
but look like a boy you put in pink so
if he was like oh you
little boys cute no she got on pink as a
fucking girl even though she look like a
boy but how did we figure that out
though how do we figure out girl Joe you
gotta ask the people who started before
Jesus Christ questions I don't know Rosa
Park questions not rose apart maybe
harriet tubman question i'll fucking
know honey they came up with this scene
I got a GED let's google it it's good
why why does the color pink be
associated with women yeah probably cuz
he's a soft color because I think yeah
it is but isn't white as well white is
my favorite color
yeah a lot of people like white I have a
white car it's for a pretty good when I
was little I wanted to be white cuz I
watched to leave it to beaver and beaver
mama was so fucking supportive mmm I
want to dedicate it for my mama she
cooked every day he wasn't called
bitches he wasn't shot at I like I want
this bitch for my mama so I wanted to be
white yeah pink they don't know they
have no idea they have no idea it's most
commonly associated with femininity they
don't have any idea why there's a bunch
of speculation all different pink was
likely associated with boy babies as
with girl babies it's a certain point in
time it was just associated with babies
we had that picture member of was it a
which which original it was the theater
Roosevelt dressed as a girl it was young
yeah they used to yeah pull that picture
because it's so bizarre people yeah
dudes dress with wigs on back in a day
yeah this is when they're babies they
dressed him as a baby when was a girl
when he was a baby why they just did it
do that the next day's a normal high
heels were actually made for men and
stuff like that like we used to dress
that's what I love them now
really that's why they love him now
think about it you could take a gay man
he'd do makeup and hair and dress way
better than normal like a regular female
has that been Snopes
we ever run that's the boy yeah okay
okay let's see Roosevelt dressed as a
girl debunked
you guys vote let's see it wasn't always
wow it's true yeah that's true
what that the that isn't an actual it's
in the Atlantic the the photographs
about girls or boys rather dressing up
as girls that's totally true
he had shoulder length hair and a hat
trimmed with a marabou feather but not
because he was a gender bender the
unexpected childhood look as a reminder
that our cultural norms about gender
specific clothing for children are a
surprisingly recent historical
development wow that is interesting man
it was 1884 he was two and a half years
old and boys wore dresses until age 6 or
7 which was also the time of their first
haircut
Wow that's so weird Franklin's outfit
was considered gender-neutral
so that outfit pull that outfit up again
that outfit was considered
gender-neutral at the time what outfit
did the outfit that he was wearing where
we think it looks like a girl look at
that's that was gender-neutral that was
a girl yeah look at his little booty
shoot and his his hair they didn't cut
your hair except like most style across
your face so that you can see where you
may be still that's not in the
Smithsonian calm also that all this yeah
I talked about
you really detail mm-hmm yes so that is
that detailed I mean for the Google
between pink and blue but I'm learning a
lot here we do want to mean that's
fascinating to me it's fat it's
absolutely fascinating to me I was
watching Fox News we talked about this
before about those women like Fox News
no not because I believe it I just cuz
it's fascinating I watch it too I love
people that are convinced of anything I
want to be convinced of god i watch
religious shows I like people that
convinced there's no God i watch atheist
shows I like watching people convince
just to study their patterns but
watching Fox News is always fascinating
to me cuz it's like this weird look into
another world that
don't ever hang out in you know I don't
know these people but these women are so
hot and they're they're so laggy there's
so much naked legs going on and I was
taking it if a man dressed like the hunt
TV it would be a fucking it was be a sin
like you would that if a guy dressed
even remotely like one of those women on
television it would be front-page news
I'd be like what the fuck is society
fallen to so if a man came in with like
mail UPS short so I mean really tight
yeah but that's not is he short or one
thing these women there's no short
there's no no answer you have to pull
down you just lift their skirt up and
start fucking it's right there their
vagina is there's a tiny little piece of
what I think you signing off here on Fox
they say they have tiny little dresses
on well that's what make people tune in
you flipping through the channel you see
a signal holy fuck exactly you know
you're gonna stop and you'll care what
they're say I mean look at Sarah Palin
they think she's fucking hot well she
was hotter back in the day she was
prettier she's starting to hit the wall
yeah but if you thought she was hot when
she was running for president like six
years ago whatever it was that would be
kind of she was kind of hot back then it
was a power thing maybe well was a
fucking god Bless America sort of a
thing son she's first of all she's a
rugged outdoorsman lives in Alaska okay
woman's been a hunter her whole life and
she's kind of pretty you'll see well you
know what she would do allegedly they
would shoot a caribou and then they
would call her for a photo op and she
yeah they would she'd get out of her car
they'd hand her the gun she'd stand down
there over the body they take a photo
and she'd hop back in the car and drive
off think they'd do it that they would
shoot an animal just specifically to
make a little hunter I know what a
caribou is you know what he carries a
deer yeah it's rainbow a reindeer rather
I guess they're but oh fuck yeah that's
what a caribou is you know they're like
when Santa has those reindeer that's
those are caribou it's in the deer
family caribou didn't come to get oh no
no they barely come to Alaska you know
they didn't believe reindeers laying on
your house if you was getting
and somebody showed up it was a fucking
sound the clown with a pitbull
did you ever teach your kids about Santa
Claus or do you just I told I tell you
when I moved in my white neighborhood I
mean I'm in Walmart one day and my son
was talking about getting something for
Christmas he was talking my son I was
like it ain't no fucking Santa okay just
tell me what you wanted I bye
so white how old was he at the time he
probably was like team so lady a white
lady and I was like how dare you not
saying so son I was like bitch he ain't
brought me no money man y'all busy white
woman fuck is you talking about you owe
my son to grow up and bleed some nice
fat chubby white dude just gonna show up
and leave tall I've got a fucking
chimney
I got electrifly place how the fuck you
gonna get in my house exactly how the
fuck is he gonna get he's gonna get in
my house so she's like don't do not tell
kids it's not Santa I put up a tree
because it's cute
yeah it's that funny that you have to
like that has to be told that's a lie
that we all agree you have to tell
children it's Easter Bunny the tooth
fairy
you would catch I would catch my step
daddy now taking my fucking tooth and
put five dollars up on there when I wake
up my mama wanna borrow five I was so
she can get high so I'm like all these
teeth you lost and did no fucking to
fair come on leave you no money
yeah the Tooth Fairy is the weirdest one
but is the Easter Bunny the tooth fairy
Santa Claus was the other one umm Easter
Bunny tooth fairy Santa Claus
Secretary's day secretary my
mother-in-law won't won't won't
celebrate Halloween because she's super
Christian and that's the devil's
birthday whoa yeah so don't buy messes
it's demons and mess and I shut the fuck
up okay my Master's demon man well what
if it's a mask of like you know I don't
pokeo or something it's a demon you
shouldn't have you shouldn't like my
mother like you should have like you
know how people have those fat
elephant's and shit on they flow mm-hmm
you can't have that because they care is
dings hold up um fat Elif
on their floor carry demons what you
know you know how you going people
housing they have those those glass
elephants and shit and tigers laying on
the floor you big black houses with yeah
the black leather cutouts in with the
sculpture yeah bet she have those no not
we're at my mother-in-law's she say that
stuff carries demons she's super saying
gulp chairs carry demons what's that I
don't know what she get this shit for I
read that one that's a tough one
like you know someone makes a sculpture
like that the eagle sculpture in San
Francisco I mean that's like I grew up I
grew up in like my mama had a Jesus
Pichet every black household had a Jesus
Christ
and I'm all of the King Picchi you
wasn't black if you didn't have no
fucking two bitches in your house how
come nobody knows who Rosa Parks's
nobody knows what she looks like I got
this photo of Rosa Parks mug shot up on
the wall and everybody thinks that it's
a Chinese Asian lady she was I just
don't understand I I don't I don't know
how that's not a famous person how's
that another famous person to see this
famous person once you tell me she was
but how's it not like recognizable like
Martin Luther King recognizable Malcolm
X recognizable if you saw a vibration
she's probably biracial oh for sure yeah
she's definitely biracial he's by the
coloration but I don't know just
probably better instead of doing that
well you could do that but it's hard to
zoom in on that yeah there you go
that's what Rosa Parks looked like
nobody knows so she was she the lady
that said no she said fuck this I'm
sitting right here
boy they fuck nobody asked her to move
she look white nobody asks her to move
but they say Dexter I think at that time
it's like she was the tipping point you
know all day imagine when they had
whites-only
fountains and shit my daddy always
talked about this year he passed about
three years ago when I brought him to
Indianapolis to live with me and my
daddy really never lived around white
people so and my son all his friends was
white so my dad was saying like hey you
gotta get Garrett he out there pulling
them little cracker kids on his
motorcycle and I'm like Danny nobody say
this shit anymore
he was he had a slave mentality well if
you stopped and thought about it for a
second like how how recent slavery was
it really kind of freaks you out because
that was 1865 they made slavery illegal
that is not that long no that is not
that long ago that is weird that's less
than 200 years stop and think about that
1865 that's not that long ago if you
lived to be a hundred years if you if
you're a hundred years old today okay
and that means that in 1914 you were
born okay if you were born in 1914 a
hundred years before that 1814 slavery
is legal as fuck yeah so that's like two
generations
you know grandfather - father - granted
this you know like if you go back like
two more generations before that that's
not that many people that's like a guy
has give a woman gives birth to a child
the the child gets raised has children
of his own and then maybe a generation
maybe maybe maybe and the people that
are alive like the the patterns of
people that are alive birth to death
birth to death there's only three three
generations of birth to death and you
got me not a guy giving birth you know a
woman giving birth to her own child and
him giving birth to his own child but a
person living from birth to death an
expedient person being born birth to
death there's only three that's not that
long and that was buying people you
could just buy them yeah take them you
could fuck them you could kill them you
could do whatever you wanted there
wasn't any laws they were yours they
were your property yeah
they would just tell you if you beat
them to tell you not to beat them as
much I don't fucking know I wasn't
around but I couldn't imagine yeah could
you even imagine can you imagine owning
a person in your backyard what's fucked
is when you hear this just as much
slavery today as there was during during
1865 if you like looked at the world the
whole world as far as the numbers what
about all these sex slaves she had going
on with the younger kids a lot of those
kids don't like it
well I will say I liked it but I don't
think those kids like he would let me go
home imagine a justified sex slavery
like look look look there's other
problems in the world they have an
energy problem this global warming yeah
yeah that's probably that's how they
look at it look you had a bad your mama
didn't have shit come on over here suck
a few digs let me feed you well you made
it work you you you were like a person
who was mean you suck is sexually
molested if you having sex with a man in
his 20s and you're 14 or you were 12 at
the time story started you're being
sexually molested yeah you made it work
but it was good sexually molested it was
horrible yeah yeah I shouldn't give him
credit for that but it was good
unemployed unemployed black man fuck
[Laughter]
photos of this don't you wanna see cuz I
really want to see means is a 12 year
old it looks like a grown woman yeah I
want to see like I want to see do you
have boobs are you holding like a teddy
bear and I'll show you me at 16 yeah
well yeah at work if I get this fucking
phone I can show you me at 16 you know
what was crazy I wasn't I was a drug
deal on his picture so my daughter was
like ah you don't look like I expected
you to look and I was like well what do
you expect and I wasn't fucking up my
teeth are you fucking crazy
you don't know the most that was the
biggest scam in the ghetto those dinners
with puddin teeth go teeth on those
crooked as black people teeth when they
should say hey dude take this dope money
and get some braces first before you
fucking crap please move before you cram
these goes on these ragged ass teeth so
you be any club this month I got teeth
in his mouth looking like a piranha
what the fuck okay explain that to me
because I'm white what is it about gold
teeth what it's not about goaty like
people are flashy
we like God we like shit that shine why
is that cuz we want to stand out and I
tell you we with black people we want
you to know we got it because you really
you come from not having it so when you
get it you tell the fucking world cuz I
was just telling my friend I said what
is it with black people that are run out
and buy $5,000 jeans it you fuckin got a
food-stamp car but your pocketbook costs
$800 you know you had a fucking you
gotta get a name-brand purse or you get
a knockoff name-brand purse for $200 and
in any fuckin real leathers don't have
no value just so people can say I'm
totally Michael Cole I'm totally over
time when we know it's not a little bit
on cuz your fucking car's raggedy and
your teeth these cricket and you got a
bad weave bitch you got a lot of kids
behind you you don't buy a Louis Vuitton
if you're fuckin you got fo five kids it
don't work like that dumb band started
to green but a Louis Vuitton it's like
not like a Ferrari like if you get a
fake Louis Vuitton what happens it
doesn't hold shit you know it is form
and they egg like is real you know what
I mean like if you have a fake Ferrari
you know you're not driving right what
if I got a fake Farrar well they're fake
Ferraris they fall apart the purses fall
apart very I bet in China they're making
fake Ferraris right now and a goddamn
assembly line
I bet this dudes out there that have
fake Ferraris they don't even know they
have fake Ferraris it's probably totally
possible I've never heard on the faint
Ferrari but I know buy some fake bags
and want to be flashy and you know and I
was gonna get a gold grill when I was a
drug deal about how the friend was like
you're not always gonna do this shit and
you have really nice teeth
so why would you fuck him up so if you
did get gold teeth they have to like
chip out the outside of it no they do
they stay what they do is they my
brother had beautiful teeth I mean he
could've did a fucking Colgate
commercial and he when they got a gold
and they they they fucking moved his
front teeth and put a gap there so they
could push the goal up and he decided I
don't like this shit this country-ass
brother of mine put a pen in his mouth
and ripped the gold off his teeth oh no
it didn't bleed he was just my brother
hillbilly okay I got two brothers with
the same name they're not tween their
name is Anthony and Tony and that they
real fucking like and
no Joe I didn't even know that I didn't
even recognize that I took my house like
pay why do your brothers have the same I
was like my fucking brothers don't have
to say to me Tony
he's like paid this the same nose oh
what the fuck that is the same name you
know what else is the same name well
John and Jack what it ain't no Johnny J
yeah John F Kennedy was Jack Kennedy
yeah John F Kennedy was Jack they called
him Jack Kennedy that's yeah it's one of
the weirdest ones that's a weird one
weird abbreviation but that abbreviation
is not always used like I know a Jack
that was born Jack like on his birth to
ever get it says jack but John is the
you know the nickname of John is Jack
it's a Joh I am young I don't know it's
good question you're 16 this photograph
though it's one of a kind
let me see that that's you at 16 with
him and that's the dude that's the
grown-ass man I had the baby back wow
that's crazy that's to do this shot you
NASA do this shot me well is this hard
to see cuz it's kind of a an old picture
yeah but what did you do this phone how
did you shoot this phone's I bought to
shit in Lowe's at the hardware store
yeah nope
yeah that's what no those are great
aren't they yeah for old people like me
who wants to see those are great for
going online now look at that web pages
can't beat it can't beat it for that so
here's me as a drug dealer I want to
show you my kids unfortunately this is a
podcast of people listen to I was
showing it to you I know no but I'm
saying that I wish that everybody who
listens it could get a photograph of
those that's your kids right here okay
that's me like 16 wow that's crazy you
at 16 with two kids and one of them
looks like it's six I'm not even fucking
around
that's crazy that's a child with
children that's a child with you you
crazy life that's Pat yes I do how did
you how did you choose the name is Pat
how'd you go with Miss Pat because I was
gonna name myself rabbit but that was
too close to my drug-dealing life and so
I didn't want to come to the stage
rabbit they're just too fuckin blood so
I was like what can I call myself and at
that time when I started being a
comedian I still had them the little
vending business at the diamond and all
my daughter school classmate works for
me so everybody called me miss Pat so I
was like what I make people respect me
miss pett so I I was like okay the key
is naming that's a good one I like this
my name is Patricia
it's very what's very easy to remember
too and it's it's unique to you
automatically know I'm black
the could be Jaden Asian know you oughta
know this pad that could be an agent a
crazy asian chick or wears tight leather
clothes or gay Asian dude no I've walked
up on people like in mainstream when
things like who perform in items like
miss pett miss Pat gotta be black it's
gotta be some Def Jam and I'm standing
I'm like no bitch fuck is you talking
about white boy with your cat jokes
because you go to a mainstream club are
you fucking here is cat jokes I'm like
one of you fucking white boys rob a bank
so you can be more fucking interesting
you give that bastard gifted bastards
yeah you had like privileged revolution
bastards I don't want to hear your cat
you don't want a monkey to change your
litter box hey come on let's rob a
grocery store bitch so we can eat let's
do some real life shit what kind of cat
jokes are you here is this Indianapolis
cat no everywhere I go they can't jump
and I don't fucking tell a cat joking
from it fucking dries my pajama you need
to go on stage of the UCB
what the fuck is that that's the hipster
club as do dudes wear cardigans and they
all have cats everywhere they put no
fucking hey I have cute two cats you do
I have two cats two dogs and 24 chickens
what a fuck do you live in California
with chickens I live I gotta tell you my
chickens Joe Joe you got a chicken store
yeah my mama had one chicken in the
backyard she had a lot of them but she
eventually killed him out so I'm telling
you the truth
hoo-wee I when my life was so bad I
would go outside every day and just tell
this chicken everything you know cuckoo
my mom and shooting it was cuckoo I
fucking hated my mama so I would talk to
this chicken and you know chicken
walking around eating shit out girl I
really thought he was concerned and was
listening to me Howdy's Lee I come home
from school and his bitch got my chicken
my only friend I was listening to my
pain by the neck and getting ready to
kill him and the chicken eyes is big and
I'm looking at the chicken and he's
looking at me and I'm like nigga did you
snitch on me and she tell me Mac look
and she killed that chicken and she made
me eat it Wow well you know that's what
a lot of people have chickens for they
kill them and eat them I didn't know I
made friends with it so I that's why I
don't have a chicken for a pit I don't
have a dog because I had a dog named pup
pup pup pup pup and kukuku and pop ice a
lot of fuck out him so when Ronald
Reagan got reelected pop up got upset
about the election I assume he jumped
out the back porch with a change on the
neck and fucking hung yourself that's
why I won't vote Republican kill my
fuckin die hey I almost moved to Canada
because of George Bush really I thought
about that shit when he read one when he
won in 2004 I was like this is this is a
crazy place to live I gotta get out of
here when he won't be one I was
seriously thinking about going to
Vancouver and I was on TV at the time I
was like I would have been hard for me
to move to Canada and still come back
and do fear factor but I was like this
is not good
this is a grin same place to live we got
to get out of here I was catlica Vince
we had to get out of here get all my
friends move to Vancouver too
I mean they all say they gonna do shit
for us but in the end we are gonna get
fucked about them they don't go fuck
about us they just wanna buy nice meals
nice suits and do the fuck they want to
do I wonder people don't care about
people anymore
when I was little Joe you could go to
the black church and eat on Sunday for
free for years until Rick Ronald Reagan
got reelected
dick I'm telling you he fucked us up
because after that they started charging
five
for the meal and I haven't been back to
the church since five bucks seems
reasonable but not when you live well
fucking enough in the 80s right no fool
Stan was once a month right that's like
ten dollars right probably 20 mi Mabel
when we didn't even eat fucking four we
ate beans every fucking day but don't
you think they like times are tough and
prices the things are expensive and
people that do you really think that
people don't care about people anymore
no not if you my friend you might
fucking free alright are we fucking
friends or what we're not fucking free
no I mean you said my fucking friend you
my friend me and I'll do anything for
you I'm not a two-faced type bitch I'm
down with you okay so people that say
they down with you to get what you got
sling some yeah this there's ever you
could say that about it is business in
this bit this is a cutthroat for this is
almost like getting a drive-by in the
hood
I disagree you know why why are you here
then you're here because we want to help
you we heard about you this is the
business this business right but do have
I'm not saying everybody's like this
business is going on right now in this
room is this business mm-hmm and in this
business we're just trying to help you
so that's bullshit what are you dis
around oh you can find those people this
is this is my thoughts on this business
yeah you can find those people in this
business but you can find those people
everywhere you could also find people
that are nice yes I really believe
people there's more nice people than
people give credit for because the
negative instances stand out it's like
when people talk about like online like
commenters on YouTube and shit like that
think about what percentage of people
that is like everyone's like there's a
perfect example that society's doomed go
read like I was reading something about
Floyd Mayweather the other day
Boyd Mayweather took a picture with his
new girlfriend and then the fucking
comments were so I think that is even
when you get on YouTube but
you get out and you talk about Beyonce
baby hair I was like these people are
human like people would say shit to me
and I like I did a podcast and I talked
about putting drugs in my baby panties
and everybody way at the time was
tweeting you to get me on so this dude
was like why would you want her own Joe
Rogan when she put drugs on my baby pan
I said hold on bitch I was 15 years old
at the time have you thought about where
I was in my life at that time
I say Plus don't judge me bitch you
probably like fucking frozen cucumbers
up your ass but nobody's coming over
your house trying to pull up frozen
cucumbers like your ass I'm not judging
you because you're very specific because
if he doesn't have frozen I mean we're
people people do they write ugly stuff
they don't have to deal with you
face-to-face yes that's see that's not a
normal way to communicate with people
you people get a free shot at you like
you're Miss Pat you know you're on the
internet you're on a video they see it
and they can just start talking shit for
free and more than one it's not
one-on-one like if you were doing that
in a room say like I would knock they
fucking ass that doesn't happen listen
if you in a room like say if you were in
a room you're talking to me and then
someone who's a youtube commenter was
sitting right there and listening to you
talk used to say someone who would say
something awful about you on YouTube if
they were sitting right next to you they
wouldn't say they wouldn't shit yeah
they wouldn't say shit and if they did
say shit they did say something rude
you'd be like where the fuck are you
coming from why are you coming at me I'm
not first of all I'm not talking about
you I'm not talking to use doesn't
concern you so why you making some sort
in their new to have a conversation with
that person and they would be shown to
be retarded and then it would be done
but they could just leave it on YouTube
that comment is permanent yes yes this
morons statement that's not supposed to
happen in nature it's just not when you
think about how many people that is
though that's a small what percentage of
the people comments on YouTube videos is
it even what I have a fuck of 1% yeah
but what is the number
I mean is it 1/10 of 1% is it even that
you could just look at the likes and
dislikes of every video and that pretty
much sums it up yeah likes and dislikes
is pretty easy but
comments sometimes are interesting
sometimes they're engage like we talked
about that with Lewis from unbox therapy
that sometimes he gets people that are
like really knowledgeable they're
interesting and they have discussions in
the put in the comments but it's the
shit like on Floyd Bay where they're
talking about his girlfriend's like wow
not just jealous hateful and they're
also they're they're they're giving in
to their situation they're giving in to
that this guy is rich and famous and a
superstar and successful and I am less I
will never be in his position so I want
to take free shots yeah I'm gonna throw
rock cause they would never say that in
his face that's like when they was going
around say Come Beyonce baby yeah who
the fuck are you to tell the Beyonce
that baby is no richer than all you
motherfuckers I don't know if that baby
want to have nappy hair her parents were
not having that baby hair was nappy or
whatever you want to call it she still
look better than your fucking baby who
was born on Medicaid bitch well again if
the baby wasn't born on Medicaid your
argument is invalid
I mean people pick at people they don't
realize that you you and you say stuff
like that they can hear it
well it's just it's stupid it's just a
stupid it's a it's it's a it's a
situation that's never supposed to
happen
human beings are supposed to communicate
with each other they're not supposed to
just communicate and when you just
communicate no one's there and you can
just say whatever you want there's no
repercussions you're in an echo chamber
you don't even have the fucking name
that you have like you're you're 69 eat
me that's your youtube name you know so
69 eat me has all these things that they
say and they could say fucked up shit on
every video they find online they're not
even a real person and they could have
20 of those names they could do whatever
they want like that situation doesn't
exist in nature but it doesn't mean that
people are fucked up it means that
there's an avenue for fucked up people
to express themselves it didn't exist
before and there's evidence of that I
had a fat girl one time I was on Bob and
Tom and I said some stuff Oh My don't
think I'm funny one that uh you know I
don't like being facto fat girls like to
eat all the time so this lady sent me
like all the wrong guys even how dare
you talk about the fat girl and why'd
you own that clansmen show with them
white dude and you did and fat girls are
six and she sent me all these fucking
coupons then she sent me all these
fucking look things for Chlo
so fat girls all own was fuckin leper
and I don't put on a leopard anyway bird
yeah leprosy hi bird that's what fat
girls were lepers and talking they
wanted to look like animals so you shoot
the shit out why did they always wear
leopard you look at line brownie master
stores they always fuck everything is
animal print
I think they trying to kill us I don't
want a shit I would black okay big girls
I'm telling you so she sent me this
jumper and she was like big girls are
sexy and so I was gonna tear her ass up
and my husband talked me out of it
what you need to do is you need to write
a bit about big girls I do everything
tygo and animals and zebra zebra paints
why is that I don't know why do you
think we want to look like a bear or
some shit it's like an attempt and
appeal the animalistic I don't buy
leopard panties I don't think I'm
serious don't want to see my big ol ass
walk around no leopard panties no
leopard bra and then I got stomach
hanging over the front of it you don't
want to see that shit no no I don't buy
like like Valentine's Day look
Valentine's Day it always a pink and red
leopard lunging the rate lunch array for
fat girls I'm not putting myself in that
shit I'm not doing it no longer no
t-shirt okay with my panties I'll be
angry
I'll pass the lingerie party when I lost
my virginity in the gravy on done lunch
array is over now seen your husband lose
all his weight and go vegan does that
make you want to do anything you gotta
know your batter I'm late I need a
sponsor yes because you hustle I hustle
my ass off so how is that good
everybody got that one thing that they
can't
campus readout and that for me is losing
I just lost 30 pounds or Nutrisystem and
say you know what I don't have $300 this
month I quit
that's fuckin Nutrisystem food is still
at the house I went straight to
chick-fil-a what is Nutrisystem how's
that work they send you like they sing
you healthy foods and meals and it works
if you can't afford it Frankie I think
wait watches the baby Richard wait watch
I can't count no fuckin points I'm busy
I got a GED I can't keep up with that
kind of shit I just move my piece I just
move my niece and her four kids and I
got time to be killing shit I can't do
that I need something you could pop in
the microwave it ain't going about your
business yeah but if you had like this
is what I believe I believe that you're
gonna be very successful that's what I
believe thank you you're gonna have
crazy crazy money and when you do are
you gonna get like a trained chef to
cook you like healthy meals and then I'm
gonna badda-bing de Broglie muscles in
calories miss patch or what we're gonna
see miss path say thank you very much
for the healthy meal you shut your door
and bolt it and then pull a drawer out
from underneath your bed stack a cake no
if I can get half of my sixth grade
figure back he'll just have fun I used
to be on 140 pounds Wow Oh God nice
round titties and both nipples that was
the good old days work your way back to
that we can make this happen it does
well you know I was eating healthy then
I move my niece and my niece was
homeless with four kids she's 23 years
old so I said okay I raised her for ten
years a mama can't make it fucked up her
life so I went home for Christmas I got
my nice folk kids and I just started
back eating I was so stressed I mean how
do you bring five people into your house
kids literally had no shoes no nothing
and I took everything I had to get these
kids back together I mean these kids
were so behind on these
they shot her four-year-old was getting
newborn shots oh my god so I had I mean
I think that that brought on a lot of
stress and I was like fuckin I'm just
gonna start back I'm sure I'm sure yeah
stress is a fucker and when you hit
stress the first thing you do when you
hit like a real bad patch is to go back
to whatever comforts you yeah for some
people its food for some people with
cigarettes for some people its booze you
know and I need to lose weight
oh my god I just need a hundred pounds
we'll do this Jess you're too funny we
got to keep you healthy
yeah all right we got to keep you
healthy I won't drop dead when are you
back here again we got to do this again
we ran out of time we didn't have three
hours oh we did up fuck I feel like I've
been here for 30 mins crazy just flew
bar hours is over
I don't know whenever you call for me
after you got an open invitation any
time you want to come on anything can I
promote my website yeah please do y'all
please y'all know my Twitter comedian
miss pett comedian miss pett Facebook
comedian like as in girl community yeah
I think that's a very controversial
thing like a lot of comedian female
comedians they just said I'm a fuckin
comedian I don't know a comedian well I
asked my friend who had the college
degree I was like I need you to spell
comedian the girl right
well good thing is if you just type in
MSP a it comes up MSP a to you and I
have a Instagram Facebook and my website
is miss pack comedy mr. Pryor comedy car
yeah miss pack company.com I want to do
a couple days yeah please join me at
Toledo Ohio
August 8th to 9th at last I'd be at the
funny bone one night only so it's very
important that you come out to the funny
bone I want to show them that I have
some fans which funny one Atlanta
he'll know it's our date date Dave Dave
funny bone yeah
funny bone Atlanta's a good spot we got
a funny bone the lamp don't know we got
my pencil on you they don't book me yet
funny bone is Columbus for ya yeah and
the day I'm in dayton dayton and Zanies
august 28th through the 31st chicago
chicago
yeah oh great room and Oklahoma City
Oklahoma City I be there September the
10th through the 13th at the loony beans
is all this on your website
all of this is on my website spat comedy
comm miss Pat comedy dot-com thank you
so much and thank you to the fans who
got me here and I want to thank my
friend Avery at Morty's comedy joint cuz
he told me three years ago he said you
get on Joe Rogan some shit might happen
and I said who the fuck is Joe and I'm
here beautiful every made it real
every diligent at Morty's coming John
and give a big shout-out to Randy who's
helping me with a project in Indy that
was a beautiful podcast there was a lot
of fun everybody thank you for having me
I'm on the first black woman the other
one sounds Chronicles baby oh shit I
broke history some DeRosa party mother
Rosa Parks of this podcast hey feel like
fur baby shut the fuck up on the first
one now it is that shit's gonna stick
alright thanks to our sponsor thanks to
honor comm go to O n ni t use the
codeword Rogan and save 10% off any and
all supplements also thanks to nature
box go get your yum Yum's on folks rich
and delicious and healthy and nutritious
nature box.com strong and go there and
enjoy it if you don't get the sriracha
cashews you're a sucker MC
naturebox.com/tyler organ get 50% off
your month's first box and thanks also
to stamps.com go to stamps calm use the
codeword je r e and save yourself some
money much love my friends will be back
soon take care
drive safe each vegetables big kiss
Oh August 1st Ace Hotel in theater
downtown LA Joey Diaz Duncan Trussell
and moi come laugh with us
[Applause]
[Music]